AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO CALL TO
ORDER THE UTILITY ENERGY
COMMITTEE FOR WAS A JULY THE
TENT.
I WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
FOR MEMBERS PRESENT.
HOLDEN HERE HOLDEN HERE
PATTERSON HERE PATTERSON HERE
BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO HERE CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HERE EDUARDO
GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES HERE MERCI CHANGE.
MURATSUCHI HERE QUIRK HERE QUIRK
HERE REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEAM.
WE HAVE A QUORUM -- I LET ME
JUST ANNOUNCED EARLY ON THAT WE
ARE GOING -- TO ADDRESS ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE HERE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT PART OF THE HEARING.
OF WILL TAKE THAT AT THE END OF
OUR SCHOOL -- FILE WHERE WE HAVE
TEN ITEMS TO ADDRESS FIVE OF
THOSE WILL BE ON CONSENT -- BUT
WE WILL TAKE UP THE ITEM -- AND
IT SHOULD HOPEFULLY WON'T TAKE
TOO LONG FOR US TO GET TO THAT
POINT OF THE AGENDA -- LET'S SEE
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT
WE CAN -- DISPOSE OF AT THIS
POINT THAT ARE ON CONSENT.
THOSE ITEMS IT'S ITEM NUMBER --
TWO SP ONE SIXTY SEVEN DOT ITEM
THREE SB ONE NINETY NINE HILL.
SB -- BUT I DON'T FOR S. B. TWO
OH NINE DODD.
AND LET ME JUST SAY THAT --
ITEMS TWO THREE FOUR AND A
THERE'S MOTION AS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ARE FOR CONSENT ITEM AND ITEM
TEN SB FIVE SIXTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR CONSENT.
AND THEN -- SO LET'S CALL THE
ROLL ON THE THE MOTION.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE.
LEO.
CARILLO I CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HI CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES I MAYOR CG MURATSUCHI I
QUIRK BY.
WORK I REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEEN.
OKAY THE ROLL CALL I MEAN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
WILLIE THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON MISTER HURT CENTER
HERTZBERG WILL -- LOOK TO TAKE
YOU NOW SINCE YOU ARE HERE.
YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE TO ITEMS BEFORE US I'M
GONNA.
MAKE YOU -- GOOD TO WILL PRESENT
TODAY BECAUSE I'M GONNA PULL
FROM THE FILE.
SB THREE FIFTY INVOLVING CENTRAL
PROCUREMENT.
OKAY THE HAD WATER.
GARCIA MEASURE OF SIMILAR.
SUBJECT MATTER DID NOT PASS.
ITS RESPECTIVE COMMITTEE IN.
I WANT TO WORK TOGETHER WITH HIM.
ON THIS ISSUE AND I THINK IT'S A
ONE OF THESE LARGER ISSUE TAKES
MORE TIME.
AND BOTH OF OUR SHOULD BE TO
YOUR BILLI WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER IN HARMONY.
BETWEEN THE HOUSE AND IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO FROM POINT FOR
THAT REASON OKAY WE APPRECIATE
THAT ROCK CRIME.
WE'VE ALWAYS YOU DO AS A TEAM
PLAYER.
I'M NOT MUCH INTO SPORTS FAN BUT
WHATEVER THE TEAM IS I'M IN.
SO -- YOUR TO PRESENT ON THIS --
FILE ITEM SIX SB.
FIVE TWENTY AND I WANT TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS ON THE ENEMY JUST
FRAME IT A LITTLE BIT THIS WAY
JUST FOR A MOMENT --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SEASON SHOWS LIKE
THE HISTORY SHE LIKES HISTORY
LESSONS BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
BEEN IN THE SITUATION NOW FOR
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS WHERE.
WE'RE TRYING.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESTRUCTURE
OUR ELECTRICITY UTILITIES WE
CERTAINLY HAVE FACED SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH
THE BILL AND YOU AND OTHERS HAVE.
A IS WE'RE CONSIDERING IN THE
ASSEMBLY WAS CONSIDERED THE
SENATE.
BECAUSE OF THE ABNORMAL
SITUATION BECAUSE OF THE EXTRA
THE THE NEW ABNORMAL.
BUT ALSO WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO WE ON THE ONE HAND MOVE
AWAY FROM THE OLD MODEL.
RIGHT.
AND AND THEN COME UP WITH A NEW
MODEL THAT SUPPORTS OUR CORE
VALUES THAT DEALS WITH THE GREEN
ENERGY ISSUES AND PLAY THAT
WORKS.
AS A SERIES OF THREE STEPS TO DO
THAT.
WE'VE BEEN ADDRESSING ALL OF
THEM LAST YEAR THIS COMMITTEE WE
DROPPED WE ADDRESS ARE A
RESOURCE ADEQUACY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WHEN WE DO THESE PLANS
WE HAVE ALTERNATIVES THAT THEY
WORK FOR THE LONG TERM.
SECOND THE BILL THAT I JUST
PUSHED OFFER TO YOUR BILL IS
CENTER BUT CAN PROCUREMENT THAT
THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
YOU'VE GOT A AS IT IS AT AS THE
LARGE ARCHITECTURE HAVE A
CENTRAL PROVIDER TODAY THE THIRD
ELEMENT OF THAT IS THE PROPER
THE PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT.
THE TERM IN THE IN AMONG
GOVERNMENT US TYPES IS POLAR.
WHAT WE'RE TRICKING TO DO IS TO
CONGESTION TO ENSURE CONTINUOUS
ELECTRICAL SERVICE IN CASE A
RETAIL PROVIDER LEAVES THE
MARKET FOR ANY REASON?
WE SAW THAT IN THE ENERGY CRISIS
TWENTY YEARS AGO.
THAT'S WE'RE TRYING TO DO SO
THIS THIS IS A WAY TO BALANCE
RETAIL CHOICE ON THE ONE HAND
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS DEALT
WITH SO MUCH ON THE ONE HAND.
HOWEVER NOT ALLOWING ALSO TO
LOAD SERVICE ENTITIES REGULATED
FROM LEAVING SOME CUSTOMERS
WITHOUT -- KEY CONSUMER AND
PRICE PROTECTIONS MORE TO TALK
ABOUT BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND I
DIDN'T HEAR SECONDS.
I HEARD A SECONDS.
I DID I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE
SHOULD PAY MORE ATTENTION.
APOLOGIES I'LL TURN THIS OVER TO
ARGUE AGO -- LET'S GO SHOULD GO
TO SCOTT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU TO CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
JOSEPH ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION CALIFORNIA AGILITY IS
EMPLOYEES I'LL BE BRIEF.
MOST OF LAST CENTURY THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY WAS THE
ONLY PROVIDER AND THE QUESTION A
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT WAS NOT
A QUESTION ANYBODY ASKED.
AND SO THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE
ESTABLISHING A PROVIDER OF LAST
RESORT.
WITH DEREGULATION WE HAVE NEW
RETAIL PROVIDERS.
AND THERE'S ALWAYS A RISK THAT
NEW RETAIL PROVIDER.
WE'LL GO OUT OF BUSINESS OR
DROPS CUSTOMERS IN THE ENERGY
CRISIS WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CUSTOMERS DROPPED
AND RETURN TO THE UTILITY.
SO WE NEED A SAFETY NET.
THE THE AFTER ALL AFTER ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS OF CALM IN THE
MARKET SINCE THE ENERGY CRISIS.
WE NOW HAVE -- A SITUATION WHERE
DIRECT ACCESS IS EXPANDING.
CCA'S ARE EXPANDING AND BY MOST
PROJECTIONS -- WITH IN THE NOT
TOO DISTANT FUTURE MORE THAN 80%
OF OUR CUSTOMERS WILL BE SERVED
BY SOMEBODY OTHER THAN THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY.
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AS ASK FOR LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORIZATION AND DIRECTION. TO
ESTABLISH A PRIDE OF LAST RESORT.
SB FIVE TWENTY DOES EXACTLY THAT.
WE CAN'T KEEP GOING WITH NOTHING
IN THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CO TO
ESTABLISH THE SAFETY NET AND
STILL IS THE PROTOCOL FOR HOW
THAT SAFETY THAT WILL BE
OPERATED -- THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL AND IT
FEELS A LONG STANDING GAP IN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHAT
YOU'RE BEHALF THE CALPERS
DISSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS A CALIFORNIA DESPITE
COUNCILMAN LESTER SEATS COUNCIL
SHEET METAL WORKERS.
VERY BRIEFLY WE GET SO CAUGHT UP
IN ALL THE NEW WHIZ BAND GIDGET
TECHNOLOGIES AND THINGS THAT WE
FOCUS ON IN THESE COMMITTEES.
THE SOMETIMES WE LOSE TRACK THE
SORT OF BASIC ELEMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE P. YOU SEE IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT CUSTOMERS ARE
TAKEN CARE OF AND THAT THERE IS
A SAFETY NET FOR THEM.
AND THIS SEEMS LIKE IT SHOULD
ALREADY HAVE BEEN TAKING CARE OF
A LONG TIME AGO IT HASN'T BEEN
IT NEEDS TO BE AND WE PERSON
I'VE A THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHERS HERE WOULD LIKE
TO LEND THEIR SUPPORT TO TO THIS
BILL [inaudible]
COME.
FOR CHEN NUMBERS REBEKAH LEE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON -- WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
WOULD HELP ENSURE CONTINUED
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO CLEAN ENERGY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
MEASURES THAT THIS.
BODY HAS PASSED REGARDLESS OF
CHANGES THAT MAY HAPPEN IN THE
RETAIL MARKET HERE TO URGENT I
VOTE.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU ONE HUNDRED STERN
AYE B. W. LOCAL TWELVE FORTY
FIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS GREG COOK
RAISING OF THE CALIFORNIA POWER
IT'S HE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR FOR
TODAY'S AMENDMENTS THANK YOU --
JAMES ISSUE WITH THAT I WORK FOR
BEGINNING -- WE'RE SUPPORTING
THE BILL.
JENNIFER THRELFALL I BEAT.
VIEW TWELVE FORTY FIVE I SUPPORT.
FONG TRYING TO BE A TWELVE FORTY
FIVE FIRST ONE PIECE ANY SUPPORT.
EILEEN SAKI IBEW TOP FORTY FIVE
IN SUPPORT.
JOSH RITTER THE IBEW TWELVE
FORTY FIVE FULLY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE HERE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MELISSA BROWN
WITH EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY
AND ON BEHALF OF KELSEY CA -- WE
HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL THAT WE WANTED TO RAISE
TODAY. ONE OF THEM IS THAT.
UNDER THE CONSTRUCT COPPERY UP
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THIS IS
AN ADDITIONAL FEES THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY FOR COMPARED TO WHAT THEY
PAY TODAY.
SO TODAY WE AS LOW SERVING
ENTITIES -- WE POST A BOND AND
THAT.
HELPS PROTECT CUSTOMERS IF THERE
IS AN INVOLUNTARY RETURN TO I
OWE YOU SERVICE BUT UNDER THIS
BILL -- THERE WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL FEES THAT WOULD BE
LEVIED ON OUR CUSTOMERS ON ALL
CUSTOMERS PRESUMABLY TO PAY FOR
THE PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT SO
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE FEES
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS ESPECIALLY AT
A TIME WHEN CUSTOMER RATES.
ARE ALREADY RISING BECAUSE OF
THE BURDENS OF WILDFIRE --
SECONDLY WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
BECAUSE UNDER UNDER THE THE WAY
THE BILL IS WRITTEN.
IT HOT TIES THE HANDS OF THE CPC
SO IT EVEN IF ANOTHER LOAD
SERVING ENTITY WAS BETTER
POSITION TO PROVIDE THE PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT FUNCTION.
THE CPUC CANNOT SELECT THAT
ENTITY AS LONG AS UTILITY
DOESN'T AGREE.
SO IT IT GIVES THE UTILITY THE
ABILITY TO PREVENT ANOTHER LOAD
SERVING ENTITY FROM SITTING INTO
THAT ROLE -- AND THEN FINALLY
WERE CONCERNED BECAUSE THE WAY
THAT THE BILL'S WRITTEN THE
UTILITY IS NOT -- ASKED TO SHOW
THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY MEET THE
CRITERIA THAT IS ASPEN ANY OTHER
LOAD SERVING ENTITY THAT MIGHT
WANT TO STEP FORWARD TO FILL THE
ROLE.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT -- FUNCTION IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO BE
HOPPING WE THINK THAT MORE
DIALOGUE IS NEEDED ON THIS TOPIC
THERE ARE A LOT OF OPTIONS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TOPIC AND
IT'S IMPORTANT NOT TO
NECESSARILY ENTRENCH ONE ENTITY
AND NOT ROLE WITHOUT CONSIDERING
WHAT ALL OPTIONS MIGHT BE ON THE
TABLE IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE WE
CAN DO THIS IN THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE.
AND EFFICIENT MANNER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK OR TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- IN OPPOSITION IN BETWEEN
IN SUPPORT I MISS THE SUPPORT
PART WE JUST MATT FRIEDMAN WITH
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK WANT
OFFER SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US WE
GOT A FEW SMALL ISSUES.
THAT -- WE STILL WANT TO WORK
OUT BUT WE THINK THIS BILL IS
DEFINITELY MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION PROVIDES THE RIGHT
SAFEGUARDS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IN OPPOSITION CAROL WE THE
SUSTAINABLE ROSS MORE PROUD --
RECIPIENT OF MC CLEAN ENERGY.
IN OPPOSITION KAREN PERKINS A
MEMBER OF THREE FIFTY BAY AREA.
AND ALSO -- CONSUMER OF
COMMUNITY CHOICE -- AGGREGATION
AGGREGATION.
AND I BELIEVE IF THIS BILL
ENCROACHES.
ON THE CCA'S -- ABILITIES. TO
PROCURE AN ENGINE LABEL C. P. U.
S. ON THE UTILITY COMMISSION TO
HAVE.
MORE POWER THAN IT REALLY SHOULD
HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE.
WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION?
IT WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE A DOCTOR QUIRK -- IF
IF THE EDISON REPRESENTATIVE
MISS LEE COULD COME UP I'D LIKE
TO ASK HER SOME QUESTIONS AS
WELL -- SO WE'LL START WITH
MISTER GRANT FROM COULD -- EAST
BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY SO YOUR
FIRST CONCERN IS THE FEE.
YOU'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT YOU
YOU SAY THAT.
THE CURRENT I OWE YOU IN THE
AREA WOULD BE THE THE STATEMENT.
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL IS
THE I OWE YOU.
DOESN'T HAVE TO GET PERMISSION.
THAT THIS IS A CPU TO SEE USE.
C. P. YOU SEE.
OUR DECISION AS TO WHO WOULD BE
THE PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT CAN
YOU EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT IN THE
BILL.
MAKES YOU THINK THAT -- THE THE
I. O. YOU WOULD AUTOMATICALLY BE
A. B. THE FIRST ONE AND WOULD
HAVE TO GET PERMISSION FOR
SOMEONE ELSE AND THE P. YOU SEE
COULD MAKE THAT DECISION WHAT IN
THE BILL SAYS THAT.
SO I BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS A
LANGUAGE ABOUT THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION BY DEFAULT BEING THE
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT.
AND IF ANOTHER ENTITY WANTS TO
STEP UP AND BE THE PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT THEY WOULD NEED TO
FILE A JOINT APPLICATION WITH
THE ELECTRICAL CORPORATION.
WHERE IS THAT IN THE BILL AND
NOW I CAN SHARE IT WITH YOU?
OKAY THE THE PROVIDER OF LAST
RESORT SHALL BE THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION PAGE.
FIVE THE SEX SUBSECTION BE --
LINE TWENTY SEVEN AND TWENTY
EIGHT THAT IS THE FRAMEWORK OF
THIS BILL OKAY.
SO [inaudible]
IF [inaudible]
IF IT -- COMMUNITY TRIES
AGGREGATOR WANTS TO BE THE
PROVIDERTHEY'D HAVE TO GET
PERMISSION FROM THE I OR YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- THEN YOUR SECOND
QUESTION WAS ABOUT THE FEE.
ARM AND THAT THAT'S WHERE I WANT
TO GO TO EVER SAID.
SO YOU'RE SUPPORTING THIS MY
CONCERN.
AND IS THAT.
EVENT WELL FOR EXAMPLE WITH
SEMPRA.
THEY MAY END UP NOT BEING AN
ENERGY SUPPLIER AT ALL.
THEY WANT TO BECOME A WIRES
COMPANY RIGHT I KNOW THAT'S NOT
THE POSITION THAT EDITION HAS.
BUT AT LEAST HALF YOUR LOAD IS
PROBABLY GOING TO SEE CA PERHAPS
MORE TO CCA'S.
PERHAPS MORE.
HOW DO YOU MANAGE TO BE A
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT WHEN YOU
NO LONGER HAVE THE GENERATION
CAPABILITY?
I THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
CURRENTLY SENDING CALIFORNIA
EDISON DOES SERVE AS THE
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT.
FOR OUR SERVICE AREA AND YOU ARE
CORRECT THAT WE ARE LOSING
SIGNIFICAN LOW TO COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATOR BUT IN RECENT --
YEAR IN THE PRISON MONTH WE ALSO
SEE THE RETURN OF THESE
CUSTOMERS DUE TO CERTAIN RATE.
INCREASES IN BEING EXPERIENCE IN.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO IT IS NOT
CERTAIN RIGHT NOW SO THERE'S
SOME LOW MIGRATION THAT'S IN
FLUX CURRENTLY AND THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO SET
BACK FOUNDATIONAL FRAMEWORK. TO
ALLOW FOR CERTAINTY IN THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT.
OKAY BUT IN THE END SINCE YOU NO
LONGER HAVE THE LONG TERM
CONTRACTS TO SERVE THESE FOLKS.
BOB YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE SPOT
MARKET IS THAT.
AM I RIGHT ABOUT THAT ARE.
THERE IS A PROVISION WITHIN THIS --
THIS MEASURED THOU WOULD.
PROVIDE SOME ABILITY FOR THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
SET RULES TO ADDRESS MY LOW
MIGRATION MATTERS SO IN CASE
THERE IS A LARGE ON PLANNED
MIGRATION THERE'S ABILITY FOR
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
TO DO SOME OF UP FRONT WORK TO
MEDICATE A THE NEEDS FOR THE
PROVIDERS TO PROCURE A LARGE
AMOUNT OF OUT OF MARKET OR LAST
MINUTE PROCUREMENT THAT COULD BE
MORE ON THIRTY THAN WHAT WE
COULD DO UNDER LONG TERM
CONTRACT SHOULD BE MORE DIRTY
BUT IT COULD.
ALSO BE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE AND
YOUR CURRENT RATE STRUCTURE
WOULD NOT SUPPORT THAT SO I I
JUST SEE SOME DIFFICULTY YOU
ACTUALLY DOING IT IF YOU'RE
PAYING.
DOLLARS -- FOR MONEY ON HER.
ATTENTION LEE THE SPOT MARKET
COULD BE QUITE HIGH YOU COULD BE
ENDING A PAIN SEVERAL TIMES MORE
THAN YOUR RATE JUSTIFIES.
HOW WOULD THE CPUC HANDLE THAT
SO THAT YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
IT?
THESE ARE ALL.
YES I THINK SO OKAY.
BUT THIS IS REALLY BEEN THIS IS
BEEN TWENTY YEARS OF THINKING.
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS AS PEOPLE
LEAVE WE HAVE A A REGULATE
STRUCTURE AND SO THE CHALLENGE
IT'S BEEN TO LITIGATION AND ALL
THESE HEARINGS AT THE P. YOU SEE
HAS BEEN.
WHAT DO YOU DO TO THE PEOPLE
THAT LIKE YOU WANNA PUT SOLAR ON
YOUR ROOF?
RIGHT AND THERE'S ALL THESE
SOCIALIZE COST EVERYBODY RIGHT
WHY IS IT THAT YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO LEAVE WE HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED THE PROCUREMENT COST IN
DIFFERENCE AMOUNTS OF THAT THE
BASICALLY THERE'S A CHARGE. TO
CUSTOMERS TO LEAVE THAT THEY GOT
TO PAY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LEFT BEHIND ART
HURT.
AND THERE'S ALSO A BIG CHARGE OF
THE WAY THE STRUCTURE WORKS THAT
IF THEY WANT TO COME BACK ON
THEY PAY MORE MONEY.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS TO GET FLEXIBILITY IN THE
MARKET TO LET PEOPLE LEAVE AND
DO ALL THE THINGS THEY WANT TO
DO.
BUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH FOR TWENTY YEARS THIS LARGE
ISSUE IN THIS IN DIFFERENT SOME
OUT SO GOING TO YOUR POINT WHICH
IS IN FACT THE WHAT HAPPENED THE
ENERGY CRISIS NINETEEN YEARS AGO
RIGHT.
IS THIS ISSUE OF WHEAT WHEAT
WHICH SAYING TO OURSELVES OKAY.
EVERYBODY'S LEAVING WHAT DO WE
DO WE AND THE REASON WE LANDED
ON ON THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES IS BECAUSE THEY ARE
REGULATED.
THEY'RE COMPLETELY REGULATED AND
THERE'S A DETERMINES THE WHOLE
PROCESS BEEN LITIGATED FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
THAT THERE ARE FINANCIALLY
SECURE THEY HAVE A BALANCE SHEET
THEY HAVE A SYSTEM THEY HAVE THE
THE THE THE INDIFFERENCE AMOUNT
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE COVERED IF
PEOPLE LEAVE SO WE DON'T HAVE
THIS BIG LOAD ON PEOPLE.
COMING FORWARD AND SO WHAT WE
TRIED TO DO TO QUITE FRANKLY THE
ANSWER IS WHEN YOU LOOKED AT
SETS SAN DIEGO.
WE SAID TO OURSELVES OKAY.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE A PROVIDER
LOSSES ARE YOU GONNA BE ABLE TO
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING LAST
RESORT MEANS LAST RESEARCH GO TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON AND YOU HAVE
THE MONEY TO DO IT.
AND THERE'S A WHOLE INTEREST IN
IN THE IN THE C. C. A.'S OF
COURSE AND AND SO THE QUESTION
IS FOR SAN DIEGO FINE IF YOU
WANT TO TRANSFER THAT.
THAT OVER THERE TO THE CCA IS
WELL THEN FINE BUT THERE HAS TO
BE A PRETTY SIX STANDARD. TO
MAKE SURE WHOEVER THEY ARE ON
THE COULD BE SOME NEW INVENTION
IT DOESN'T MATTER WE GOT TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON AND THE REASON
JUST YOUR LAST POINT ON YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT REGIONAL COSTS.
IT IS REASONABLE COSTS OF COURSE
THIS COSTS THAT'S THE IDEA OF
KIND OF THE IN THIS FRENCH
CHARGE AND WE PUT REASONABLE IN.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHOEVER'S GONNA CHARGE WERE
PROTECTING THE CONSUMER SO IT'S
A DELICATE BALANCE OF A LONG
DISCUSSION AND ALL OF THIS STUFF.
AND HOW DO YOU GET FLEXIBILITY
TO THIS NEW OR DYNAMIC BUT MAKE
SURE PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED.
AND THEN WORK ON SOMETHING THAT
WORKS WITH THAT'S THE FRAMEWORK
AND THAT I THINK ANSWERS THE
FORM YOUR QUESTIONS BUT WE DID
MAKE THOSE CHOICES OKAY BUT THE
PROBLEM HERE IS THAT THE AMOUNT
THAT PEOPLE WOULD PAY TO COME
BACK. TO P. JEANNIE F. R. A C.
C. A. R. LOST CREDIT RATINGS IN
AND COULDN'T BY THE ENERGY THEY
NEEDED.
WHICH IS A SORT OF THING WE
WOULD LOOK AT SAY IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
GET THE LONG TERM CONTRACTS
BECAUSE OUR BALANCE SHEET ISN'T
GOOD ENOUGH.
THE PEOPLE WOULD COME BACK
THERE'S A FAIRLY SMALL FEE
INVOLVED.
WITH PEOPLE COMING BACK AND THEY
COULD.
IN NO WAY IF THERE IF THEY HAD
TO GO TO A TIGHT SPOT MARKET.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT THEY COULD
IN FACT GET THERE -- NOT PUT A
HUGE BURDEN ON THE SYSTEM FOR
THE PEOPLE PARTICULARLY FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO SAY STATE WITH THE
WITH THE I. O. U..
THE SUMMER QUIRK YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED EXACTLY ONE OF THE
BIG PROBLEMS AND ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THIS BILL WHAT THE
SCENARIO YOU'VE IDENTIFIED IS
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
ENERGY CRISIS.
WHEN ENRON DUMPED?
YOU KNOW A A LARGE NUMBER OF
HIGH LOAD CUSTOMERS BACK ON THE
UTILITIES IN THE PC HAD TO MAKE
IT UP AS THEY WENT ALONG.
AND THOSE CUSTOMERS THE CAME
BACK DID DID END UP PAYING MORE.
SO DID THE CUSTOMER SHOULD STATE
WE ALL PAID MORE THAT'S RIGHT WE
ALL PAY MORE AND IT WAS YOU KNOW
A DISASTER.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THIS BILL
DOES IS SAY TO THE COMMISSION.
FIGURE THIS OUT IN ADVANCE SO
THAT WE'RE NOT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO FLY BY THE SEAT OF THE PANTS
IF THAT SHOULD HAPPEN BUT FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE PROTOCOL IS GOING
TO BE IN ADVANCE SO THE PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT.
KNOWS WHAT TO DO AND KNOWS WHAT
THE CHARGE SHOULD BE.
IT JUST SEEMS BETTER TO PLAN FOR
AN ADVANCE THAT DIDN'T MAKE IT
UP ON THE FLY YES SOMEBODY WHO
STAYED WITH THE I OWE YOU -- I
WOULD FEEL VERY UPSET IF A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE HAD TO COME BACK.
AND MY COSTS WENT UP THAT'S THE
PURPOSE IN DIFFERENT CHARGE
THAT'S THIS WHOLE TWENTY YEARS
OF LITIGATION.
BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S UPSET THAT --
YOU PEOPLE OVER HERE WANT TO
LEAVE WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF US
AND WE NEED A SYSTEM TO PROTECT
SOCIETY AND THAT'S WHY THESE
CHARGES ARE ARE IMPOSED UPON
PEOPLE THAT LEAVE WHETHER IT'S
DIRECT ACCESS PEOPLE.
WHOEVER IT MIGHT YEAH BUT COMING
BACK THAT COULD YOU KNOW IF THEY
HAVE TO GO TO THE SPOT MARKET IN
THE SPOT MARKET IS TIGHT.
THEN THAT COULD BE YOU KNOW THEY
COULD END UP WITH.
THE PROCUREMENT COST BEING TWO
OR THREE TIMES WHAT THEY WERE
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO'D STAYED AND
MY CONCERN IS SPREADING THAT OUT
TO THE PEOPLE WHO STAYED.
ARE SAY THE PEOPLE OF NEWARK OR
PLEASANTON THAT DIDN'T JOIN IN
THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY.
WITH THOSE FOLKS HAVE TO PAY.
FOR THE FACT THAT.
SCCA COLLAPSED -- I'M SURE EAST
BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY WELL BUT
I'M JUST GIVING THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE.
AND I'LL GET YOU TO GET TO YOU
IN A SECOND BUT MY CONCERN WOULD
BE.
I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T GO ON TO SAY THAT THE THE
COMPANY THAT COLLAPSED SHOULD
HAVE TO PAY THE COST FOR THE
PEOPLE CAME BACK.
THAT'S MY BIG CONCERN SOME OCCUR
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED THE
COMMISSION TO ESTABLISH THE
RULES TO PROTECT THE CUSTOMERS
AREN'T THE ONES COMING BACK YEAH.
YEAH SO THEY THAT NEEDS TO BE IN
THERE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT IS BUT IT
REALLY THOSE FOLKS SHOULD BE
HELD HARMLESS.
IF PEOPLE COMING BACK --
SUDDENLY RAISE THE AVERAGE COST
OF ENERGY.
SO THAT'S MY CONCERN.
YES MISS BROWN I MIGHT BE ABLE
TO RESPOND THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS ARE AWARE OF ONE
IS THAT -- CURRENTLY THE I. O.
USED TO SERVE AS THE PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT SO THAT ROLE IS NOT
BEING UNFAITHFUL TODAY SECONDLY
ON THE COMMISSION HAS A
PROCEEDING.
THAT - ESTABLISHED A BOND THAT
ALL LOW SERVING ENTITIES HAVE TO
PAY AND THAT BOND IS MEANT TO
COVER ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT
COULD BE IN KERN AND PUT UPON
ANY CUSTOMERS THAT REMAIN WITH
UTILITY.
SO THAT IS THE MECHANISM THE
FINANCIAL MECHANISM IN PLACE
TODAY AND THE AMOUNT OF THAT
BOND IS ACTUALLY BASED IN PART
ON MARKET PRICES SO AS THE
MARKET PRICES OF ENERGY.
GO UP -- YOU'LL SEE THAT THE
BOND THAT WE ARE REQUIRED TO
POST GOES UP AS WELL YEAH BUT
THOSE ARE THOSE THE SPOT PRICE.
PRICES AT THE CLOSE ON SPOT
MARKET PRICE PRICES BASED ON
SPOT MARKET PRICES MY CONCERN
THOUGH IS THAT.
IF WE GET TO THE SITUATION WE
HAD IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE
THE SPOT MARKET SUDDENLY WENT
WAY UP.
AND SO I'M NOT SURE THOSE BONDS
WILL DO IT NOW.
THAT SO WELL I THINK I'VE I'VE
GOTTEN THROUGH THAT PART.
NOW THERE IS ALSO THE SECOND
THING YOU BROUGHT ABOUT YOU
TALKED ABOUT IS THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE A A FEE PAID TO THE
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT.
AND THAT HE IS DETERMINED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION AND TO PASS THE
SENATOR AUTHOR.
OR ONE OF YOUR EXPERTS.
HOW IS THAT FEE LIKELY TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE CPU CD YOU MAY
OR MAY NOT HAVE AN IDEA BUT IF
YOU DO -- WHAT IS THAT FEE
INTENDED TO DO AND HOW IS?
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
CRITERIA WILL BE USED TO SET IT.
I THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A
ALREADY THAT THE PC HAS QUITE
YOUR TO SET FEES WE PUT THE WORD
REASONABLE AN THAT'S THE WHOLE
STRUCTURE 90% OF WHAT THEY DO
OVER THERE.
AS IT RELATES THE ENERGY UTILITY
MARKET IS LOOK AT PEOPLE'S
REIMBURSEMENT SO WHAT THE COSTS
ARE WITH THE RATE OF RETURNS ARE
IN THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
AND WE PUT THE WORD REASONABLE
IN BECAUSE WE JUST IN ONE SO YOU
COULD CHARGE A FEE WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE P. YOU SEE
THROUGH ITS ORDINARY STRUCTURE --
LIMITS IT TO MAKE SURE CONSUMERS
ARE PROTECTED -- BUT WHAT WOULD
THAT FEES SUPPOSEDLY PAY FOR
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE A LOT OF
COSTS.
UNTIL THE THING HAPPENS MAYBE
THERE'S SOME PLANNING COSTS BUT
I WOULD THINK POLICY WOULD BE
FAIRLY LOW I THINK THAT'S TRUE.
OKAY SO IT'S TRUE WE WOULD WE
COULD ALL IT IS LIKELY IT'LL BE
FAIRLY LOW BECAUSE IT ALL IT IS
IS PLANNING.
IS THAT YOUR AT THIS POINT YES
OKAY ACTUALLY IT'S A SMALL
NUMBER BUT YOU GOT TO PROVIDE
FOR AND THAT'S WHAT WE DID IT
AND WE PUT REASONABLE TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS OKAY.
UP MISPRINT WAS -- ANOTHER
CONCERN YOU HAVE.
SO ONE OF THE OTHER CONCERNS
THAT WE HAD WAS THAT -- THAT THE
UTILITIES ARE NOT ACTUALLY HELD
TO THE SAME STANDARDS THEY DON'T
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO MEET THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE PUT INTO THE
BILL FOR OTHER LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES TO MEET IN ORDER TO
BECOME THE POLDER.
I DON'T SEE THAT THAT COULD THE
AUTHOR.
THAT.
MIA IT WILL THERE THEY ARE THE
POLAR THEY THEY THEY ARE ALREADY
REGULAR UTILITY.
BY OPERATION OF BUT BUT THAT THE
ENTIRE STRUCTURE OF THE LAW.
I MEAN I I DON'T APOLOGIZE MAYBE
JUST MY INABILITY UNDERSTAND BUT
THE IDEA THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS THEY
ALREADY ARE THE POLAR WHAT WE'RE
REALLY DOING HERE.
IS SAYING OKAY HE'S A PROVIDERS
LAST RESORT THAT MEANS YOU'RE IN
TROUBLE SOMETHING BIG HAPPENED
AND YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE IS A
GOVERNMENT WE ARE AS WAS
INDICATED.
PLANNING IN ADVANCE SO WE'RE
TRYING TO BE THOUGHTFUL AS WE'VE
NOW TORN APART THE WHOLE
STRUCTURE OF OUR ENERGIES
PROVIDED.
AND COMPLETELY TURNED IT UPSIDE
DOWN AND WE SAID WE BETTER MAKE
SURE SO WE AVOID ANOTHER ENERGY
CRISIS WE HAVE PART OF THAT PLAN
THAT SOMEBODY'S A PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT.
AND THE STARTING POINT IS THE
EXISTING PEOPLE SO WE'RE NOT
DESIGNATING THEM UNDER NEW
THINGS THEY ALREADY ARE THE
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT IN THE
LAW.
THEIR OBLIGATION IS TO SERVE
THAT'S WHAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
CODE SAYS THAT'S THE ENTIRE
STRUCTURE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I'VE KNOWLEDGE
WHERE SOMETHING IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE SEEING HERE IS JUST ONE
DOLLAR YEAH WILL NOT LET ME.
TO MY REGARDING OUR IT IS BETTER
TO JUST FOR A SECOND I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT MY MISSING
SOMETHING APOLOGY YOU'RE NOT
MISSING ANYTHING BUT I DO WANT
YOU TO FILL BUT YOU.
ASKED THE QUESTION BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU ASKED HAS BEEN ANSWERED
OR A COUPLE DIFFERENT ALL RIGHT
NOW THIS IS A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
THE QUESTION IS [inaudible]
ARE THE IF THE CPU CA BECAME A
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THEM BE ANY
DIFFERENT THAN THEY WOULD BE FOR
AND I OWE YOU.
IN MY READING OF THE BILL IS
THAT THEY BE THE SAME THEY
BECOME A PUBLICLY REGULATED
UTILITY.
AND THEY WOULD HAVE EXACTLY THE
SAME REGULATIONS AS THE PUBLIC.
ART PUBLICLY REGULATED UTILITY
BUT IS THAT THE CASE OR IS IT
DIFFERENT -- DOCTOR QUIRK AND
THE VERY LAST PAGE OF THE BILL
WHICH SAYS THAT.
IF THE IF EAST BAY COMMUNITY
ENERGY BECAME THE PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT.
IT WOULD BE REGULATED AS A
PUBLIC UTILITY FOR THE PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT SERVICES.
BUT JUST FOR THOSE SERVICES.
OKAY SO THEY WOULD BE AGAIN IT'S
AT THIS SO OF THE THREE
OBJECTIONS. ONE OF THEM IS THE
FEE WHICH WOULD BE LOW.
THE OTHER IS THAT -- THAT THEY
WOULD BE REGULATED IN THE SAME
WAY NOT A DIFFERENT WAY.
SO I DON'T SEE THAT THE MAIN
CONCERN THAT I THINK YOU STILL
HAVE THOUGH IS THAT -- THE
DEFAULT IS THE IS STILL GOING TO
BE THE ARM UTILITY THE UTILITY
AND YOUR CONCERN THAT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE THE CASE.
I'M CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE TO
OBTAIN THE UTILITIES PERMISSION
IN ORDER TO APPLY TO BE THE
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT AND I
ALSO REMAIN CONCERNED THAT WE
HAVE TO APPLY AND MEET CERTAIN
STANDARDS.
THAT THE UTILITIES HAVE NOT
DEMONSTRATED THEY CAN HIT.
LOOK AT FINANCING OF I HAVE NO I
I I JUST DON'T BUY THAT ARGUMENT.
I THINK THAT IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
BUT LET'S GET BACK TO IT WHY DID
YOU MAKE THE I. O. U.'S HAVE TO
GET PERMISSION WHY NOT JUST LET
THE C. P. U. C. DECIDE.
IF I COULD -- DOCTOR QUIRK
ARNOLD IF YOU CAN ANSWERED --
BUT THEN I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
MOVE TO DOT -- SHARE THIS MATTER
SUCI AND SORT OF GIVE OTHERS A
CHANCE TO WEIGH IN ON IT BUT
SENATOR IF YOU.
LIKE THE ANSWERS IN THE MARK
ALSO ADD INTO THIS STUFF WITH
THE ANSWER REALLY IS IS THAT
THEY ARE THE PRIOR PROVIDER OF
LAST RESORT AND THEY GOT TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT THAT WHOEVER'S TAKING OVER
HAS THE FINANCIAL CAPACITY AND
THE ABILITY TO DO IT THIS IS A
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT THIS IS
THE EMERGENCY PLAN.
AND SO WE HAVE A STRUCTURE
THAT'S BEEN IN CALIFORNIA FOR
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS.
AND WE'VE DEVELOPED THAT
STRUCTURE WE HAVE THESE THEY
KNOW THE POPE POLLS ANOTHER
WIRES AND OTHER SYSTEMS IN ORDER
THE IT'S GOING ON THERE THE
PEOPLE THAN THE MAIN SERVICE
PROVIDERS THIS THE OTHER
ENTITIES THAT ARE IN THE THING
WHETHER IT'S DIRECT ACCESS OR
WHATEVER THE OTHER PLAYERS ARE.
HAVE THEIR OWN LITTLE MARKETS
AND STUFF AND IT SEEMS TO ME IS
THAT IT'S THE MOST PRUDENT THING
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
THE CASE.
AND AND IT IT ALSO TO ME IS THE
BEST CHECK AND BALANCE ON THE
DEAL INSTEAD OF JUSTGOING TO
THE GOVERNMENT SAYING OKAY YOU
GO FIGURE THIS OUT LET'S GIVE
THEM SOMETHING ELSE TO DO ON TOP
THE WILDFIRES -- I SEE ALL RIGHT
WELL I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THEN THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND --
MISSED RESEARCH.
THANK YOU I THINK A MOST OF MY
QUESTION WAS ANSWERED -- BUT
SENATOR.
THIS IS A LITTLE -- FOCUSING ON
THE ISSUE OF WHY THEY'RE IN
THERE NEEDS TO BE A JOINT
APPLICATION SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE JUST SAYING THAT
THAT IT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE THEY
THEY ARE THE EXISTING POLAR AND
AND THAT SOMEHOW NOT JUST THE P.
YOU SEE BUT THE UTILITY.
SHOULD SOMEHOW BE AN A VETTING
PROCESS -- IN IN TERMS OF THE
POLAR THAT WOULD REPLACE THAT I
OWE YOU YEAH EXACTLY I MEAN NOT
NOT IT'S ONLY THIS IS A LAST
RESORT THIS THE EMERGENCY PLAN
THIS THE RIP CORD.
AND THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE INVOLVED YOU'RE GONNA GIVE
IT TO A BUNCH OF FOLKS IN THE PC
FIND THEY CAN REVIEW IT.
BUT CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN IN THE THE THE THE
BASICALLY THE CATBIRD SEAT THE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TAKING ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT OF PLANNING
AND WORKING SO HARD.
SHOULD TAKE THE FIRST SCRUB AT
IT AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE IN TERMS OF THEIR
CUSTOMERS TO BEING HAVING
SOMEBODY ELSE HOLD THAT RECORD.
THE EVENT THAT THERE'S URGENCY
AND I JUST IT'S JUST A REAL KIND
OF CONSERVATIVE RESPONSIBLE
APPROACH. TO WHAT SHOULD
SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN TO AN ENERGY
CRISIS ADD TO LIVE THROUGH IT
AND YOU WE CAN'T TAKE A RISK AND
SO THE IDEA IS IF IT'S A LITTLE
TOUGHER STANDARD.
SO BE IT LET'S PROTECT PEOPLE
AND MAKE SURE WE DON'T MAKE A
MISTAKE AND NOT JUST TURN IT TO
THE P. UC BUT CREATE PART OF TO
CHARGES THAT THEY GOT TO GO
THROUGH BED BED GIVEN THAT
YOU'RE.
SUCH A YOU KNOW STUDENT OF
HISTORY AND THAT YOU ALWAYS
SHARE YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF THE
HISTORY WITH US -- BEAT IS
NEEDED TO TRUE THAT.
TO THERE THERE HAVE BEEN --
THERE IS A HISTORY OF UTILITIES
THAT ARE BUT THAT OR TRY TO
UNDERMINE -- CCA'S -- ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY'RE FOR ST GETTING
STRAIGHT YES OF COURSE.
AND LET'S NOT THE HOUSE HERE WE
PASSED THE CCA'S ROSTER Là TWO
THOUSAND ONE GIRL MEGAN'S BILL
IS INTENDED FOR COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT PURPOSE IT'S NOW BUT
ALL CHANGE I HAVE NO OBJECTION.
I ONLY CARE THAT THAT BALANCE
SHEETS ARE REAL AND THEY COULD
REALLY DO IT IN LA COUNTY WAS
THIRTEEN MAYBE IT SEVENTY EIGHTY
PEOPLE ON ANOTHER GREAT PEOPLE I
KNOW MOST OF THEM ARE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE.
BUT THIS IS THE REAL DEAL AND
LET'S JUST MAKE SURE IT WORKS
THAT'S ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN
THE VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT IT BUT
YES OF COURSE.
IS BEEN TENSIONS THERE'S I USED
TO BE THE SOLAR BUSINESSES
TENSIONS WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DIFFERENT KIND OF SOLAR
TECHNOLOGY THAN I AM IT'S JUST
THE WAY IT IS.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT'S NOT A
BIG DEAL IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS
I'M JUST THINKING THIS IS SUCH A
BIG DEAL FOR GOVERNMENT.
THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT'S ALL AND THESE FOLKS HAVE
BEEN THAT PROVIDER AND THEY
BETTER MAKE SURE THAT THE NEW
PEOPLE CAN TAKE OVER THE
CONTROLS.
ALL RIGHT WELL I'M NOT HAPPY
WITH THE JOINT APPLICATION BUT
I'LL STILL BE BETTER FOR YOU.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OF SENATOR THANK YOU I'VE YOU'VE
CERTAINLY MADE THE CASE WE DO
APPRECIATE THE THE CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN RAISED -- BY THE CCA --
INDUSTRY AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS
THE MAIN THE MARKET CONTINUES TO
GET FRAGMENTED AND WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW ALL OF THIS
ULTIMATELY COMES TOGETHER AND
SOLIDIFIES DOWN THE ROAD.
BUT IN THE MEAN TIME WHEN WE SEE
SUCH -- DISRUPTION IN THE MARKET
PLACE THAT -- WHEN THAT THE I.
O. U.'S ARE LOOKING AT A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF FUTURE --
HAVING SOME TYPE OF SYMBOL OF
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT -- SEEMS
TO BE A PRUDENT.
WAY TO GO -- BUT WE OBVIOUSLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE MARKET
PLACE CONTINUES TO BE VIABLE FOR
SOME DAYS TO CONTINUE TO GROW TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE AND EXPAND IN
THERE IS THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
GROW INTO.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO CUT THAT
SHORT BELIEVE ME -- BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL HAS A
SINGULAR FOCUS AND THAT IS.
IF -- AS YOU PUT IT -- THE NEED
TO PULL THE RIPCORD -- PRESENTS
ITSELF THAT WERE NOT STUMBLING
AROUND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
REALIZE THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
RECORD FULL.
TIME SO -- WE ARE RECOMMENDING.
A PRODUCTION OF THIS BILL DO
PASS -- TO WITH AS AMENDED --
ACCEPT THEM JUST AND ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS -- LET'S SEE THIS IS
GONNA BE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SOME APPROPRIATIONS.
THERE IS A MOTION AND I JUST
GONNA CLOSE TURN TO YOU FOR
CLOSE I JUST VERY BRIEFLY LOOK.
WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF HEADLINER
BILLS OVER THE LAST MANY YEARS
ABOUT DOING WERE YOU KNOW.
ALL KINDS OF ISSUES ON ON
CONSERVATION AND ISSUES RELATING --
TO THE R. P. S. STANDARDS AND
PERCENTAGES AND ALL THESE
HEADLINE BILLS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT.
THIS IS NOT A HEADLINE BILL THIS
IS A BILL TO PREVENT HEADLINES
SO THAT WE ARE LET LEARN THE
LESSONS OF HISTORY.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAS
DILIGENTLY AS POSSIBLE -- HAVE
ABOVE ROAD MAP IN A PLAN FORWARD
AS WE BEGIN TO REINVENT THE
INDUSTRY AND WITH RESPECT -- TO
ON GIVEN THE CHOICE A COMMUNITY
THERE'S NOTHING HERE THAT SAYS
YOU CAN'T DO IT IT JUST SAYS IF
YOU WANT TO BECOME A A PROVIDER
OF LAST RESORT.
WE'LL PUT THE EMPHASIS AND BOLD
LANGUAGE ON PROVIDER OF LAST
RESORT BECAUSE THERE'S NOBODY
ELSE THAT WITH THAT I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
OKAY WE APPRECIATE THAT ROLL
CALL ON THE MOTION.
SB FIVE TWENTY THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE.
I CUT A DEAL.
I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudble]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO.
JEAN OUR KING HI.
ARE YOUR BILL HAS TEN VOTES IT
IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MEMBERS DATA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FOR THE AT
A TIME AND ATTENTION THIS
PAIRING SUPPORT MATTER THANK YOU
OF COURSE.
SEE WE WILL -- MOVED TO ITEM
SEVEN SENATOR STERN.
NO I'M SORRY I'M SORRY -- AGENCY.
MISS SAYS.
SKINNER WERE FOLLOW ORDERS SO.
BEAR WITH US A SENATOR STERN
WILL YEAH.
SO WELL WELCOME.
SENATOR SKINNER YOU'RE HERE ON
SB.
FORTY NINE MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND I GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SINCE WE
HAVE A MOTION I DO APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK WAS JUST WORTH IT
TOO QUICKLY INDICATE THAT THE
POINT OF THE BILL IS THAT.
WE ALL HAVE NOW SMART METERS
SMART THERMOSTAT SMART AIR
CONDITIONERS ANOTHER APPLIANCES
AND WE HAVE THE SMART PHONES.
AND IT A BILL LIKE THIS ALLOWS
US TO TO BETTER CONNECT THOSE
TWO THINGS SO THAT WE CAN MANAGE
OUR ELECTRICITY USE.
AND MATCH IT BETTER TO THE TIME
WHEN ELECTRICITY IS BEING
GENERATED WHICH IS SMART WHICH
CREATES GRID RELIABILITY.
AND WHICH USES ARE BRILLIANT
RENEWABLE.
OF THE GENERATION.
THE MOST OPTIMALLY AND WITHOUT
ASKED ME WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO I TO ME PHÃN HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL -- STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL -- ASK FOR A
THAT.
HI MY NAME IS A LIVE YOU RAISE
THE SERRA I'M WITH A COMPANY
CALLED FROM CONNECT WHERE A
DEMAND RESPONSE SOFTWARE COMPANY
FOR RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- ECHO.
YOU CAN GO FURTHER IF YOU WANT
YOUR NUMBERS MAKE IT A CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
ANTACID IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL.
A SENATOR OF THE AMENDMENT YES --
APOLOGIES I SHOULD ALWAYS OPEN
WITH THE FACT THAT I AM TAKING.
THE AMENDMENTS I HAPPILY ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE LISTED
IN THE ANALYSIS AND APPRECIATE
THE WORK WITH YOUR COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF A TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT WE HAVE A MOTION SENATOR WE
DO APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS ON THIS BILL AND
YOU'RE A WILLINGNESS TO SEE THE
HOW TO MOVE US IN A NEW
DIRECTION AND A VERY EFFICIENT
WAY SO WE THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
WILL.
ASK FOR THE ROLE DID YOU HAVE A
SELECT A CLOSE APPRECIATE YOUR
AYE VOTE.
OKAY LOCAL PLACE.
SB FORTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO BURKE.
BURKE HI CARILLO.
CARILLO I CHEN [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I IT WATER
GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
WHERE CITY?
WHERE CITY AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REYES?
REYES I SANTIAGO.
TEAM FOR TING HI. EIGHT VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT AND WE WILL BE
THE ROLE [inaudible]
SENATOR STERN.
YOU'RE HERE -- FOR SEVEN SB.
FIVE TWENTY FOUR YES SIR
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THIS.
TRY TO MAKE IT LOOK AS EASY AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
[inaudible]
THERE.
PURSUIT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
FIRST FIRST OFF I WANTED TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING. TO THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS APPRECIATE THE STAFF
WORK ON THIS. ONE THAT EXCLUDES
THE ADDITIONAL LABOR COSTS
CAUSED BY USE WITH SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORK FORCE IN THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS TEST AND ONE THAT
ENSURES THAT -- THERE'S SOME
CLARITY AROUND WHAT IS IN IS IN
AN ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECT IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE'VE COME.
TO SOME GOOD AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN -- OURS ARE SUPPORT
SPONSORS AND SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS CONCERNS AS WELL AS
THE CHAIR SO I APPRECIATE THE
DILIGENCE ON THAT.
BOOK WE NEED GOOD QUALITY WORK
GOING ON WHEN IT COMES THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCIES SPACE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND RIGHT
NOW WE'RE PAYING.
FOR PROJECTS THAT WE'RE REALLY
NOT RECEIVING THE BENEFITS FROM --
THE SHODDY WORK GOING ON OUT
THERE -- FOR LARGE COMMERCIAL
PROJECTS -- THAT WHERE
INSPECTIONS ARE TOUGH TO TO
ENFORCE AND WE'RE REALLY NOT
ACHIEVING THE BENEFITS BOTH ON
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION SIDE
BUT ALSO ON A WORK FORCE
FAIRNESS SIDE I THINK.
IT'S SOMETHING WEVE GOT A
REMEDY.
THE THE SPACE IS A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THE FACT IS THE
CONTRACT NEED TO DO WHAT THEY
SAY THEY'RE GONNA DO AND
HOPEFULLY THIS IMPROVES THE
QUALITY.
OF THE PROJECTS GOING ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HE'S OUR
WORKERS ALSO WERE WHAT THEY
OUGHT TO BE PAID AND MOVES US
pEMISSIONS -- GOALS AT THE SAME
TIME -- WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR DIG INTO
SOME DETAILS.
HAVE SCOTT WHICH HERE -- BUT TO
HELP WITH THAT AS WELL AND THE
RESPECT THE ASPIRIN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH A
BEHALF THE SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL.
THE STATE'S ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS -- THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS AT THE P.
YOU SEE THE REBATE PROGRAM SO
YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH THAT
HAVE OPERATED FOR YEARS.
I THINK THEY YOU KNOW THERE ARE
OVER BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FIVE
IF I'M NOT INCORRECT -- TIME AND
TIME AGAIN THE ANALYSIS.
OF THOSE PROGRAMS BUT IF YOU SEE
HAVE SHOWN THAT WE'RE NOT
GETTING THE RETURN FOR THE
DOLLAR THAT WE COULD WE'RE NOT
MAXIMIZING THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
RETURN THAT WE COULD BE GETTING.
AND ONE OF THE TOP REASONS THAT
THEY HAVE PINPOINTED IS BECAUSE
OF IT -- SHODDY OR INAPPROPRIATE
INSTALLATIONS OR INSTALLATIONS
THAT ARE DONE IN A WAY THAT
MAXIMIZE THE EFFICIENCIES THAT
COULD BE OBTAINED.
SO WITH THIS BILL DOES IS WOULD
APPLY ON JUST PROJECTS OF FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR GREATER
RICHARD LARGE.
COMMERCIAL PROJECTS --
PREVAILING WAGE AND A
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT THAT THAT
THE WORK FORCE BE A SKILLED THAT
CONTRACTORS TO DO THE THAT LARGE
SCALE WORK.
HAVE A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE -- WE THINK IT'S A
REASONABLE COMPROMISE WERE YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY PROJECTS A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE ARE
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE.
LESS THAN FIVE I THINK WAS
LISTEN TO THAT WELL I WON MISS
WHAT I THINK IS LESS THAN 5% OF
THE PROJECTS.
I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY MUCH
SMALLER THAN THAT.
I SO WE WERE TRYING TO APPLY
THIS REQUIREMENT DOWN TO
SOMEBODY COMING INTO A HOUSE TO
REPLACE A A WATER HEATER.
INSTALL HIGH EFFICIENCY PUMP ON
A POOL -- BUT REALLY JUST LARGE
COMMERCIAL PROJECTS WERE TALKING
ABOUT COOLING TOWERS HE
REPLACING HEATING AND AIR
CONDITIONING UNITS PUTTING IN --
ADVANCED LIGHTING CONTROLS
SOPHISTICATED PROJECTS THAT
REQUIRE A SOPHISTICATED
WORKFORCE.
SO WE WERE WOULD BE HERE TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS WITH
ORIGIN I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK -- OR TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I CHAIR NUMBERS I TO BE FOUNDER
PRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FISSION SEE END OF A MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL RESPECTFULLY -- AND
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE AMENDED TO
THE BILL AND WE REPRESENT OVER
SEVENTY COMPANIES WHO DO THE
LARGEST BUILDING COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL PROJECTS AND WE CAN'T
SUPPORT IT SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORK FORCE.
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAS BEEN
WONDERFUL BUT WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS IN YOUR PRE SHEET THE
EFFORTS OF THE STAFF AUTHOR --
AND THE SPONSOR UNFORTUNATELY
THE CURRENT -- AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE ATTEMPT TO MITIGATE THE
COSTS IMPACTS OF THIS NEW
APARTMENT BUT THEY DO NOT OFFSET
THE COST.
WITHOUT AN OFFSET THE INCENTIVE
FOR LARGE PROJECTS SUCH AS
REFINERIES AND FOOD PROCESSING
WHICH LIVER THE MOST UP HOWEVER
SB THREE FIFTY BENEFITS. TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PROGRAM
DISAPPEAR.
ENTIRELY BECAUSE THE COST OF THE
PROJECT IS GREATER THAN THE
BENEFIT. FOR THIS REASON WE HAVE
OFFERED AMENDMENTS WHICH WE
BELIEVE ARE COMPLETE COST OFFSET
WE ARE HOPEFUL THE AUTHOR
SPONSOR AND COMMITTEE WILL
ACCEPT THESE MOMENTS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
I THINK YOU HAVE A COUPLE YOUR
TALK ABOUT THIS.
JUST HAVE WHICH GET CLEAR HERE
I'M JUST BECAUSE I BECAUSE I I
THOUGHT WE HAD TALKED THROUGH A
MEN'S WITH BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION.
TALK ABOUT PROJECTS THAT
UTILIZES SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORK FORCE SHALL BE PRESUMED TO
HAVE.
A 1100% NET REALIZATION RATE IS
SOUNDING FAMILIAR FOR PURPOSES
OF ANY A COST EFFECTIVENESS
ANALYSES AND BE DETERMINATION OF
AND USE CONSUMER OR CONTRACTOR
INCENTIVES.
LOOK INTO YOUR CONSULTANT. FIVE
THAT THAT SOUNDS LIKE.
WHAT WAS DISCUSSED?
WE WERE FOUND YES THERE OKAY
WITH THAT AND THAT THAT'S
ALRIGHT WITH YOU ALL -- DO I
NEED TO GO BEYOND THE SCOPE OF
WHAT IS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
AND THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS
WHAT I UNDERSTOOD THE AUTHOR TO
AGREE -- TO SO THOSE THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
SO THIS DOES NOT CAPTURE THE
SPIRIT OF THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OR IS THIS.
I'M SORRY.
THE COMEDIAN ALICE'S REFLECTS
WHAT WOULD BE THE INCREASED COST
THAT WOULD BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE WORK FORCE REQUIREMENT.
IN WOULD ALLOW FOR COSTS
JUDGMENT BASED ON THAT.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THAT OKAY
HOUSE -- MISTER CHAIR I YES SO I
HAVE YOU HAVE YOU ALL SEEN THAT
THE LANGUAGE I JUST READ OFF IS
THAT BEEN REVIEWED BY THE CHAIR.
OKAY -- THAT WAS A COMPROMISE I
WAS HOPING WE COULD LAND ON IT
WAS GOOD WITH THE PROPONENTS AND
THE OPPONENTS HERE TODAY -- SO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU WANT TO DO
HERE -- I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT I
WAS ACCEPTING.
YES.
IN A MONTH.
IN MY TESTIMONY I WAS SPEAKING
TO WHAT WAS ALLEN AND COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
SEEMS.
FOR TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH THE
SAME GOAL THAT WE'RE ALL WORKING
TOWARDS BUT I THINK WE TAKES
MORE CONVERSATION BUT WE
CERTAINLY ARE COMFORTABLE WITH
THE COMMITTEE PROPOSED
[inaudible]
GUIDE.
I MEAN I'M I'M A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH.
SORT OF AN AUDIBLE ON THE LINE
WHERE WE HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO I'M SO SORRY I
DID NOT INTEND THIS TO BE AN
AUDIBLE I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS
LOST AND IN TRANSLATION HERE --
WE HAD THAT LANGUAGE.
I THINK WE'RE GOOD WITH WHAT'S
IN FRONT OF US -- BUT I MEAN I
BUT THEY'RE NOT CERTAIN.
I UNDERSTAND THAT -- BUT I ALSO.
RECOGNIZE THAT THE THE COMMITTEE
HAS HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
THE OKAY THE ANALYSISAND
BECAUSE I'M NOT REFUTED AND NOT
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO MAYBE WE'RE GOING TO THE SAME
PLACE BUT I I I'M.
A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE AT THIS
MOMENT -- ESPECIALLY WITH THE
COMMITTEE NOT HAVING HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FULLY.
REVIEW IT AND APPRECIATE.
THE HARMONIOUS -- ELEMENTS OF IT
THAT IS DESIGNED TO BE I I JUST.
I THINK I'M GONNA HAVE TO BE
LOCKED AND WHERE WE ARE RIGHT AT
THE MOMENT BUT HOW FIRMLY LOCKED
ARE YOU IF WE CAN WORK WITH --
BOTH PROPONENTS AND THE
OPPOSITION AS WE PROCEED I DON'T
WANT TO AND AROUND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF BUT BUT WHAT I WOULD I
GUESS MY MY OFFER OR MY THOUGHT
WOULD BE.
IF WE CAN CALL THIS A TRY TO US
THIS IS THE LAST POLICY
COMMITTEE ON THIS ONE SO I I'M --
IF YOU KNOW I ONE OF ONE OR TWO
WHEN WE LET'S LET THE OPPOSITION --
GOOD ARE YOU HERE FOR A TEST
MONNING FINISH THE TESTIMONY AND
LET'S FACE.
IT WILL.
SURE -- MATT CLUB SCENE ON
BEHALF OF THECALIFORNIA SOLAR
IN START ASSOCIATION I REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR WITH THE AMENDMENTS
FOR OUR SECTION IN THE ANALYSIS
WE'D BE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION --
WANTED AND JUST QUICKLY FLAG
THAT ONE OF THE CITATIONS
TECHNICALLY ARE IS REPEALED BY
SUNSET AT THE END OF NEXT YEAR --
WE THINK THAT LEDGE COUNCIL CAN
FIX THAT SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE -- NO ONE ELSE.
ANYONE WITH ANY MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO PUT ON THE TABLE -- LET ME
TURN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
SEE IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
THOUGHTS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
REFLECT ON DR QUIRK.
SO WHAT THE THE OPPOSITION AT
THE TABLE FROM THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY COUNSEL IS ASKING.
FOR IS IF THE LABOR IS MORE
EXPENSIVE THAT THERE BE -- MONEY
FROM THE FUND PAY FOR THE
ADDITIONAL LABOR.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING.
FOR THAT'S THE ADDITIONAL COST.
BOB.
DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA.
OF THE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT ARE SPENT ON THIS HOW MUCH
ARE IN THESE LARGE PROJECTS.
AND FOR EXAMPLE IF IT'S A
REFINERY I'M PRETTY SURE THAT'S
GOING TO BE UNION LABOR ALREADY.
MANY OF THESE PROJECTS WILL BE
UNION LABOR.
CAN YOU DEFINE SOME OF THE
PROJECTS WHICH ARE NOT UNION
LABORER HOW MANY ARE THERE HOW
BIG AN ISSUE IS THIS MISS.
SOME OF A RECORD I CAN TELL YOU
THAT IF IF MY MEMORY SERVES ME
CORRECT.
THE IT'S IT'S ROOM A ONE ROUND
2% OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
PROJECTS GO TO THESE LARGE
COMMERCIAL PRIZE THAT'S FROM THE
SENATE ENERGY COMMITTEE NOW SAYS
IF I RECALL CORRECTLY -- SO IT
WOULD DEPEND ON YOU KNOW WHAT.
WHAT -- YOU KNOW MARKET YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OF THIS
TYPE OF ENERGY EFFICIENCY WORK
ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE IN IS
BEING DONE.
WITH CONTRACTORS THAT TYPICALLY
WOULD BE.
UNIONIZED CONTRACTORS IN THE BAY
AREA MOST OF ALL THE BAY AREA
AND FRESNO IN.
IN -- IN LOS ANGELES IN SAN
DIEGO IN PLACES LIKE THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME OTHER PLACES WHERE
THEY WOULDN'T BE -- BUT TO THE
AMENDMENT I THOUGHT THAT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
GOT TO THE HEART OF THIS ISSUE I
THINK IT'S A VERY SLIGHT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO AND
WE'RE WE THINK THAT THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES.
GETS TO THE POINT -- BUT THAT'S
YOU CANNOT I'M HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR ON TRYING --
TO MARY THESE BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK WE'RE THAT FAR OFF FROM
THE THE WORD SMITHING THAT THE
OPPOSITION WAS CONCERNED WITH
AND STILL FEELING THE INTENT OF
THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS WHICH
WAS ABOUT. TO REITERATE FOR
THOSE FOLLOWING ALONG IN THIS IN
THE WEEDS HERE.
I THINK THAT THE COMMITTEE
HOUSES PURSUANT TO THIS SECTION
ANY ADDITIONAL LABOR COSTS THIS
IS YOUR LINE RESULTING FROM THE
USE WAS SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH.
CERTAIN CHAPTERS SHALL BE
EXCLUDED FROM THE PROJECT COSTS
OF THE COMMISSION'S COST
EFFECTIVENESS TESTS.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE NOW SAYS.
WHAT I JUST MENTIONED IS THAT?
THEY'RE PRESUMED TO HAVE A 1100%
NET REALIZATIONRATE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS ANALYSES.
AND THE DETERMINATION OF AND USE
CONSUMER OR CONTRACTOR
INCENTIVES SO I THINK IT'S SORT
OF ON THAT.
THAT PIECE OF IT -- SO I'M OPEN
TO WORKING THAT THROUGH I JUST
LIKE THE LANDED WELL.
WE'LL LET ME LET ME JUST SAY.
AND I APPRECIATE THE THE EFFORT
AT THIS POINT TO TRY TO TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BRING TO MARRY
THE TWO BUT I THINK THAT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS -- WAS VERY
THOROUGH VERY COMPLETE BASED ON
UNDERSTANDING THE DYNAMICS IN
FRONT OF US THAT IT ALSO IN.
VAULT COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE P.
YOU SEE -- AND SO THIS ANALYSIS
HAS BEEN BROUGHT TOGETHER WITH A
LOT OF CARE AND I THINK
THOUGHTFULNESS AND SO -- WE'LL
HAVE IT MY RECOMMENDATION IS --
THIS BILL MOVES WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS REFLECTS ON AND I I'M
SORRY THAT SOMETHING DID
WHATEVER HAPPENED.
HAPPENED BUT IT WE WE TOOK WHAT
WAS IN FRONT OF US WE ANALYZE IT
AND WE MOVED FORWARD FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO REVIEW THE BILL.
CUT THE MOTION THAT MOTEL OKAY.
THE TICKET AND I'D LIKE TO
CLARIFY.
A LOT SECOND THE MOTION BUT THAT
THE MOTION BE THAT -- THE BILL'S
MOVED TO THE AMENDMENTS AS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SO THAT'S BEEN MODE AND
SECOND.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS DR
YEAH I WOULD JUST SUGGESTED AT
THIS POINT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY.
PROJECTS WILL BE AFFECTED BY
THIS.
AS WE SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IF IN FACT PROJECTS GET.
DON'T GET DONE WHICH IS WHAT
YOUR CONCERN IS THEY END UP
COSTING 50% MORE WHICH I DOUBT
HAPPENS FIRST OF ALL MOST OF
THEM ARE PROBABLY ALREADY LABOR --
HIGH CLASS LABOR LABOR UNIONS
BUT IF I WOULD SUGGEST IF YOU
FINDTHAT THERE IS AN ISSUE HERE
THAT YOU BRING IT BACK -- NEXT
YEAR AND THAT WE LOOK AT THAT AS
A SEPARATE ISSUE.
GIVE UP I THINK WE CAN RESOLVE
THIS MISTER JEFF I MIGHT EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE RESTORED I
UNDERSTAND.
THERE WE HAVE BEFORE US AND THE
MOTION INCLUDES THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTHING ADDED TO IT AT
THIS POINT SO I THINK THAT THE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON WORD
SMITHING IS OFF THE TABLE AT
THIS MOMENT -- SPUR SEARCHING.
NOT ON THE AMENDMENT BUT JUST.
GENERALLY MAY MAY MAKE A COMMENT.
YES THANK YOU -- BUT I JUST
WANTED -- TO THE INDICATE MY
SUPPORT FOR THIS EFFORT AND I I
SEE A THE SUFFERED THE SERVER
STERN AS PART OF OUR ONGOING
EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT AS WE
WORK TOWARDS -- GREENER AND
CLEANER ECONOMY THAT WE MAKE
THAT TRANSITION WITH UNION JOBS.
AND THAT I'M FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
OF CREATING AND PROTECTING UNION
JOBS AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
GREEN ECONOMY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS.
A WE DO HAVE A MOTION IT'S BEEN
SECONDED SENATOR YOU HAVE A
CLOSE.
SURE -- BEFORE I CLOSE CAN I GET
THE COMMENT FROM THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT WHAT THEIR OUTSTANDING
ISSUE WOULD BE WITH THE KERN
AMENDS -- I KNOW WHAT THAT
WILLOWS WILL GOING FORWARD WE
WILL LET THE TWO OF YOU DISCUSS
THAT AFTER WE'RE TAKING A VOTE
ALMOST LIKE THAT FOR THE
COMMITTEE YOU CAN GET IT FLAG
AND THEN SLUGGERS AFTERWARDS A
STARK AN IMPACT ON WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF US TODAY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO SUPPORT THE
THE MERITS OF YOUR BILL WHICH IS
IN FRONT OF US TODAY AS AMENDED
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR GOOD
WORK BECAUSE YOU ARE.
DEDICATING THE SIR I'M JUST
APOLOGIZING FOR IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT FELL THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
THERE WASN'T A COMMITTEE THAT
BECAUSE THE MISUNDERSTANDING.
THERE'S NO OTHER QUESTIONS ROLL
CALL ON THE MOTION.
THE SAYS IT SAYS IN THE A SB
FIVE TWENTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I PATTERSON BY
PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO I'D CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
MURATSUCHI MAYOR CITY I QUIRK.
WORK I REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING.
SB [inaudible]
FIVE TWENTY FOUR FIVE I NONE.
OF IT HAS MY ROSE THE MOTION
CARRIES WILLIE THE ROLE OF
SENATOR HILL.
BRING US HOME SENATOR HILL.
SB FIVE FIFTY MOVE THE BELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE CHAIR
FOR THE GREAT WORK AT THE HELP
ON THIS MEASURE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SIR IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE HERE -- TO TESTIFY OR TO
GIVE SUPPORT TO THE BILL.
WITH THE BEEN IN THE IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SAY NONE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE.
HEARING NONE. TO LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH ME AT FIVE OF THEM OKAY
ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION.
SB FIVE FIFTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
HI HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON HI BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
AT WATER GARCIA.
MAYES MAYES I MAYOR SU CHI.
CHI I QUIRK T<c.cyan> ORG I AGREE</c>
YES.
REYES I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
JEAN [inaudible]
TING HI.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES OF THE
BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN I'M GRATEFUL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
I WILL NOW TRANSITION -- TO ITEM --
ELEVEN WHICH IS -- A. B. -- TEN
FIFTY FOUR WE'LL BE HEARING THIS
BILL TODAY -- PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT -- TWO THIS IS A
CONCURRENCE -- INCIDENT
AMENDMENTS.
AND SINCE MY CELL PHONE.
MISTER MAZEN AS BURKE WILL BE
PRESENTING THE BILL I'LL TURN TO
OUR VICE CHAIR IF HE WOULD BE
WILLING TO SHARE.
AND WE'LL GIVE OURSELVES AS JUST
A FEW MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL
[inaudible]
THE TREND.
BECAUSE THE WHOLE.
VILLAGE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THERE'S YEAH THREE ARE OKAY
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A TWO MINUTE.
TWO MINUTES OF RECESS TO ALLOW.
MEMBERS TO AND WE'RE GOING.
TO THEN WE'RE GOING -- TO BUT
BEFORE WE RECESS LET'S LET'S SEE
GO BACK THROUGH THE FILE.
AND HAVE MEMBERS OUT ON WHO WORK
HERE AND ALSO TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT COLOR SUCH AS STARTED
TALKING.
AB FORTY NINE THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO EGGMAN.
A A SB [inaudible]
FORTY NINE EGGMAN I OF EDUARDO
GARCIA [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TIM [inaudible]
A TAKING OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
SB ARE ITEMS TWO THREE FOUR
EIGHT AND TEN WITH.
ITEM TEN WITH AMENDMENTS AND
THEY'RE ALL GOING TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BURKE.
HER GUY.
CHEN.
GEN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I THAT WATER GARCIA.
AS. THREE SI SANTIAGO.
TEAM.
TING I'D SAY A FEW WORDS.
EVERYBODY IS ON OTHER SHE SB
FIVE TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THAT AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN.
OF SB [inaudible]
FIVE TWENTY YES [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SB FIVE TWENTY FOR THE MOTION
THIS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
THIS IS SB FIVE TWENTY FOUR
STERN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I HAVE WATER GARCIA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
AND SB FIVE FIFTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BURKE.
HI BURKE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I THAT WATER GARCIA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
AS RIGHT MEMBERS THE EIGHT BE
ONE ZERO FIVE FOUR MISTER CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR OF
MEMBERS WE ARE HERE TODAY 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN FIFTY FOUR NOT JUST BECAUSE
THE IMPACT OF WILDFIRES ON OUR
STATE.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE INCREDIBLE
DEVASTATION CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES HAVE INFLICTED ON THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS.
THE COST TO CONSIST COSTUMERS
AND THE IMPACT ON SOLVENCY OF
ARE THE PROVIDERS OF POWER TO
ALL OF US.
CLIMATE CHANGE HAS CREATED A NEW
WILDFIRE REALITY FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE'S FIRE SEASON IS NOW
ALMOST YEAR ROUND.
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ACRES OF CALIFORNIA WILD LANDS
ARE CLASSIFIED AS UNDER VERY
HIGH OR EXTREME FIRE THREAT.
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION ELEVEN MILLION PEOPLE.
LIVES LIVES IN THE HIGH RISK
AREA.
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE IS
IGNITING AN EXCESSIVE BUILDUP OF
DRY BRUSH FROM POOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN SOME AREAS BUT
INCREASING OCCURRENCES OF
HIGHWAY AND LOW HUMIDITY IS
INCREASING THE CONTACT BETWEEN
UTILITY LINES ENTRIES BECAUSE AN
IGNITION.
EXACERBATED FURTHER BY DEAD AND
DRUG DYING TREES [inaudible]
THE RESULT. FIFTEEN OF THE
TWENTY MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN THE STATE'S HISTORY
HAVE OCCURRED SINCE. TWO
THOUSAND TEN OF THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES HAVE OCCURRED
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHETHER YOU
TO THE UTILITY WAS PPROVED
MANAGER OF ITS EQUIPMENT OR
NELIGH NEGLIGENT OPERATOR.
UTILITY OPERATOR EXPOSURE TO
GREATER LIABILITY FROM
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IS
BECOMING THE NORM.
AND MORE OF OUR NEIGHBORS THE
VICTIMS OF THE DEVASTATION.
COSTS EXCEEDING INSURANCE
PROTECTION DOWNGRADING CREATED
CREDIT WORTHINESS AND INCREASING
POTENTIAL FOR BANKRUPTCY HAS
COMPROMISED THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SAFE RELIABLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE POWER. TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AB FIFTEEN TEN FIFTY FOUR WILL
PAVE THE WAY FOR UNPRECEDENTED
SAFETY INVESTMENTS BY THE I. O.
U.'S WITHOUT PROFITS FOR
SHAREHOLDERS.
FORCE THEY ARE USED TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR WHILE FIRE
SAFETY RECORD AND PERFORMANCE
AND PROTECT CUSTOMERS AND
TAXPAYERS FROM HOLY BEARING THE
COST OF DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
FACILITATE CUSTOMER ACCESS TO
SAFE RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE
POWER BY PROVIDING A DURABLE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEMS ARISING
FROMTHE UTILITY COSTS WILDFIRES
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES A NEW WHILE
FIRE SAFETY DIVISION
ADDITIONALLY WITHIN THE CPUC.
NO LATER THAN JULY TWENTY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
DIVISION WILL BE TRANSFERRED TO
THE OFFICE OF ENERGY.
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY WITHIN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
THE BILLS ALSO ESTABLISH
PROCEDURES AND STANDARDS
APPLICABLE TO CATASTROPHIC
WELFARE PROCEEDINGS AND
STANDARDS APPLICABLE TO
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES THAT HAVE
IMPACTED OUR COMMUNITY.
A NEW PRUDENT MANAGER STANDARD.
ESTABLISHED WELFARE FUND AND
MECHANISMS TO CAPITALIZE THE
WILDFIRE FUND.
I'LL NOW TURN THE OF
PRESENTATION OVER TO MY JOINT
AUTHORS OF FOR THEM TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO SHARE WITH YOU
AS WELL BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
NOTHING IS CHAIRMAN OF JUST TO
KEEP MY COMMENTS -- SHORT --
COULD BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE'VE
HAD THIS IS BEEN A LONG PATH
THAT TO GET HERE I THINK LAST
YEAR.
A MANY OF US ON THIS --
COMMITTEE SPENT AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE -- BACK IN JANUARY I HAD
AUTHORED A CATASTROPHIC WELFARE
FUND BILLS I HAD MET I THINK
CONVERSATIONS WITH EACH OF YOU --
WE'VE -- BEEN UP THIS WEEK AFTER
THIS BILL HAS BEEN BEFORE AS THE
LANGUAGE FROM FROM LAST WEEK IN
AND I THINK I'VE I'VE SAT DOWN --
WITH EVERYONE OF YOU THOUGH I
THINK I WILL ADD TO THIS IS THIS
IS NOT.
A PARTISAN ISSUE HI THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT IS IMPORTANT TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS NOT
A DEMOCRATIC BILL IT IS NOT A
REPUBLICAN BILL -- IT IS -- BUT
AS OUR BILL -- AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO TO BE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH I THINK THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS TO BE
PRAISED.
OF FOR THE COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
IN WHICH THEY'VE THEY'VE WORKED
I BRING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS --
TOGETHER AND I'LL BE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OUT MISTER VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS I IT SIMPLY ISN'T ENOUGH
TO CREATE A FUND FOR FUTURE
FIRES I'M WITHOUT THE SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THIS BILL WOULD ONLY
REALLY SERVE AS A TEMPORARY FIX
TO WHAT HAS PROVEN TO BE AN
ONGOING PROBLEM -- AT A PLAN TO
ADDRESS WILD FIRES IN THE STATE
MUST BE COMPREHENSIVE AND
RESULTS REDUCING CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES FROM OCCURRING IN THE
FIRST PLACE -- THE CHAIR WENT
OVER AT THE NEW SAFETY AND CAL
BILLY BILLY STANDARDS -- AND A
PROTECTIONS A CALIFORNIA'S --
WILL HAVE AS A RESULT OF THIS
BILL -- AND ALSO THE COMPANION
BILLS -- IN ESSENCE -- THE THE
OUTBOARD THAT WE ARE PROJECTS
THAT WE ARE CREATING WILL NOT
STAY WHICH I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
IT WILL START UNDER THE PC BUT
IT WILL NOT REMAIN UNDER THE P.
C. AS OF AS PER THE CHERUB GEN
JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT WILL
BE TRANSFERRED FROM THE PC TO
OFFICE OF ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
SAFETY WITHIN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY -- AND WHAT
THIS WILL DO WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT ALL LECTURE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS REVIEWED ASSESS BY EXPERTS
FOCUSED ON DEVELOPING BEST
PRACTICE FOR WILDFIRE REDUCTION.
ALSO WORTH MENTIONING IS THE
I'LL USE WILL HAVE TO SPEND FIVE
BILLION IN AGGREGATE ON FIRE
SAFETY A MITIGATION OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS AND
SHAREHOLDERS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
RUN A RATE OF RETURN OR PROFIT
FROM THIS INVESTMENT --
ENCOURAGING INCREASED WELFARE
SAFETY SPENDING AND HIGHER
UTILITY SAFETY STANDARDS REDUCE
THE OCCURRENCE OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES -- AND IT WHICH WAS
RESULT IN SAVINGS TO THE STATE
AND CONSUMERS.
I DID FISH CHILI IF THE BILL'S
SUCCESSFUL REDUCE FOR FUTURE
RELATED FIRES FINANCIAL RISK
UTILITY CREDIT RATINGS CAN
REMAIN STABLE AND EVEN IMPROVE.
ACCORDING TO THE LA -- EVERY
TIME THE BOND RATING AGENCIES
DOWNGRADE THE UTILITIES THERE IS
A CORRESPONDING INCREASE THE
COST OF BORROWING FOR THE
LEXICAL CORPORATIONS.
IN ADDITION TO SAVING REPAIR
MONEY THIS BILL TAKES STEPS TO
DECREASE THE CHANCE OF FUTURE
FIRES INCLUDING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE SAFETY
CERTIFICATION WITHIN.
THE ADVISORY BOARD THAT REQUIRES
UTILITIES TO TIE EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION TO SAFETY
PERFORMANCE CREATED SAFETY
COMMITTEE WITHIN THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS COMPLY WITH WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS AND PASS A
SAFETY CULTURE ASSESSMENT.
FURTHERMORE AS THE CHAIR STATE
TO CREATE A NEW PRETTY
MANAGEMENT STANDARD THAT IS
ALIGNED WITH THE FORK STANDARD
DEPRIVE PROVIDE MORE CLARITY TO
THE UTILITIES.
THE PROVISIONS OF AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR AND ITS COMPANION BILLS
WILL ALLOW YOU UTILITIES TO
OFFER SAFE AND AFFORDABLE POWER
THROUGH THE STATE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT ENDEAVORS TO
MINIMIZE AND PREVENT UTILITY
COSTS WILDFIRES FROM HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IN DOING SO WE CAN PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
BECOMING VICTIMS NOT ONLY OF THE
DEVASTATION AND DESTRUCTION OF
WILDFIRES.
BUT THE UNPREDICTABILITY OF
UTILITY COSTS AS WELL AND WITH
THAT AS WELL AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN ITEM
[inaudible]
OTHER -- RESEARCHER IF I COULD --
BUT WE HAVE I AM A PORT THAT WE
HAVE -- AUTOMOTIVE SALAS FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHO'S HERE --
FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND ALSO
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE THAT THEY HAVE AND WE
HAVE BETTER MCCOLLUM WHO'S HERE
FOR REPRESENTING A FROM THE
ASHES.
OF WHO WILL. ONE OF OUR
WITNESSES OKAY.
BASICALLY A COUPLE OF MINUTES.
BUT I'M GONNA BE GENEROUS WITH
THE CLOCK.
ARE ON BOTH SIDES SO THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I AM PATRICK MCCALLUM
I AM REPRESENTING A GROUP CALLED
UP FROM THE ASHES -- UP FROM THE
ASHES REPRESENTS THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND VICTIMS THAT HAVE
SUFFERED FROM I. O. U. CAUSE
FIRES OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE BUTTE
FIRE THE THOMAS THE WALLS THE
THE NORTH BAY.
AND THE CAMPFIRES THERE'S ALSO
FORTY ONE LAW FIRMS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN IT.
AND WE ARE HERE A TODAY A FIRST
OF ALL.
MY COLLEAGUES THERE ARE SOME
VICTIMS TO VICTIMS THAT ARE HERE.
THAT I DON'T SEE THEM IN THE ON
ITS SCOTT WOULD YOU HELP.
WOULD YOU GUYS MIND COMING UP
BECOME RIGHT BEHIND THE FIRST
PERSON IN THERE AND STUFF THIS
THE FIRST TIME THEY TESTIFIED
THAT IT'S IT'S A MOTIONAL TO
TELL THEIR STORIES.
THE WILDFIRES.
AS MR MAYES INDICATED DO NOT
DISCRIMINATE.
THE IMPACT OF WILDFIRES IN
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR THEIR STORIES --
IS VERY POWERFUL AS YOU'VE HEARD
MY STORY.
CHANGES YOUR LIFE FOREVER.
AND WHAT WE'RE HERE TODAY IS
WHAT I WANT TO FOCUS IS ON HIS
THREE ISSUES.
WHAT DOES IT DO FOR SAFETY?
AND ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT IT
DEALS WITH SAFETY.
HOW DOES IT IMPACT RATE PAYERS
AND FINALLY WHAT DOES IT DO FOR
CURRENT VICTIMS?
SO.
WE PUT TOGETHER LAST YEAR YOU
PUT YOU PUT TOGETHER LAST YEAR
AND SB NINE A ONE A SERIES OF
STANDARDS AND SAFETY MEASURES.
THE MOST CRITICAL PIECES IN OUR
MIND WAS THE INDEPENDENT
MONITORS COULD GO ONE PLACE.
WE PRESENTED THE JUDGE ALSOP
THAT A FIFTY PAGE
RECOMMENDATIONS HE'S ADOPTED
THAT THE CPUC IS ADOPTED THAT.
THIS LEGISLATION IS
COMPREHENSIVE IN SAFETY.
WHAT WE WORRIED ABOUT AND WHAT
YOU WORRIED ABOUT IS FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS YOU WILL SEE
PROTECT THE P. JEANNIE AND
ADDISON?
VERY AGGRESSIVE BROWN WHAT
AGGRESSIVE BROWN WHILE FIRE
SAFETY.
WHAT ENSURES US THREE YEARS FOR
FIVE YEARS SIX YEARS FROM NOW
THAT THEY'VE DONE IT?
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS PUT
TOGETHER A DEPARTMENT AND A
CERTIFICATION ANNA PROCESS WITH
WITH VERY WITH PEOPLE WITH THOSE
TALENTS TO ENSURE THAT
MEASUREMENT CONTINUES AND IT
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT JUST
HAPPENS IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
AND THAT'S BEEN THE PAST IT'S
BEEN IN PLACE.
WE BELIEVE THAT IS A CRITICAL
PIECE WE HAVE READ IT.
WE'VE MET WITH THE GOVERNOR WITH
THAT WITH THE STAFF WE'VE TALKED
EACH OF YOU COLLECTIVELY.
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WITH THAT
IN PLACE.
WE WILL BE MUCH MORE ASSURED
THAT THE DEVASTATIONS THAT WE
SAW IN THOSE BIG FOR FIRES WILL
BE LESS DEVASTATION LESS
IMPACTED TO HAPPEN.
THAT'S THE FIRST THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECE WITH THAT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR SAFETY WITH
CLEAR STANDARDS WITHIN IT. EIGHT
PAIRS.
VERY COMPLICATED AND ANALYSIS --
BUT THERE ARE FOUR FIVE
DIFFERENT FACTORS ARE THE CHANGE
IT.
BUT IF YOU DO PASSED IF YOU
DON'T PASS THIS.
THEN IT'LL BE SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASES FOR REPAIRS OUR
ANALYSIS IS WE HEARD FROM A
BERKELEY PROFESSOR -- AND SENATE
UTILITIES IS A SUBSTANTIAL
SAVINGS FOR P. JEANNIE AND
EDISON CUSTOMERS WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB.
TEN FIFTY FOR A WEEK TO WALK
THROUGH THE FOUR FIVE WAYS IT
GETS THERE.
AND IT'S IN THIS IS A SOON TO BE
THE W. R. CAPITALIZATION AS AN
INCREASE NOT AS A CONTINUATION.
AND IT'S FOR IT.
IN A DIFFERENT FACTORS IT'S
PROBABLY NEUTRAL TO A SLIGHT
INCREASE FOR EDISON CUSTOMERS
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE FLOOD.
DECREASE AND FEES FOR MOST OF
THOSE -- CUSTOMERS.
IN REGARDS TO VICTIMS -- THERE
ARE THREE AREAS THAT IT HELPS
VICTIMS PROVIDES MAJOR LEVERAGE
IN OUR NEGOTIATIONS WITH P.
JEANNIE AND SOME LEVERAGE IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THAT ISN'T.
THE FIRST PIECE IN IT IS THAT IT
HAS I AM GOING.
TO ASK THAT.
WE WE GET TO A CONCLUSION.
ASK THE CPUS WE'VE BEEN
GENEROUSLY P. AND WE STILL WELL
ANYBODY SPECIFICALLY CELEBRITY
SUMMARIZE IT.
TOO CERTIFIED THE VICTIMS ARE
MADE WHOLE THE SECOND IT GETS TO
A SPEEDIER AGREEMENT AND
BANKRUPTCY AND THIRTY IS A
HEALTHIER COMPANY GOING FORWARD
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS -- IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE ADD NAME AND POSITION.
ACTUALLY MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN I
THINK I WAS GOING TO BE ONE OF
THE WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
BEHALF OF THE OF THE BILL.
SIT IN THE CHAIR AND YOU GET THE
TIME.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD SCOTT WHICH
WOULD BE A MINUTES OKAY.
YES -- OUT WHICH ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES ONE THING I'D I'D LIKE
TO JUST CORRECT FROM MISTER
MCCOLLUM'S TESTIMONY IS I THINK
THIS CONSENSUS THAT THERE IS A
ZERO RATE IMPACT REPAIRS -- IN
THIS PRESENTATION IN THIS
PACKAGE AND THAT'S ONE REASON
WHY WE SO STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
THIS TO PROVISIONS PARTICULARLY
FOR WORKERS CURRENTLY SECTION.
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR OF THE
UTILITIES CODE PROVIDES THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE A MERGER OR
ACQUISITION.
OF A TELECOM OR UTILITY THERE IT
GOES BEFORE THE C. P. U. C. FOR
A REVIEW TO ENSURE THAT IT'S IN
THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST.
THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THIS THAT
ENSURES THAT THE ISSUES
AFFECTING WORKERS ARE PENSIONS
MIGHT WE HAVE FIFTY THOUSAND TO
CHILE WORKERS AND I ARE USING
CALIFORNIA ANOTHER FIFTY
THOUSAND RETIREES.
THERE'S LANGUAGE WE LIKE TO
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION THE
AUTHORS FOR ENSURING THAT
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF REVIEW AND
PROTECTION. FOR WORKERS THE
SECOND SIGNIFICANT THING THAT
THAT SECTION DOES IS CURRENTLY
FIFTY FOUR DOES NOT.
IS NOT APPLICABLE WHERE YOU HAVE
A SELLING OF ASSETS BY A UTILITY
AND THAT'S REALLY WAS NEVER A
CONCERN WHEN WE HAD
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS OWNING
UTILITIES NOW THAT WE HAVE.
PRIVATE EQUITY WE HAVE HEDGE
FUNDS THAT ARE ARE OWNING MOST
OF OUR UTILITIES THE CONCERN IS
THAT THEY MAY GO IN AT SOME
POINT AND START CHOPPING UP THE
UTILITIES AND SELLING OFF IN
PIECES IN A THAT MAY NOT RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF P. YOU SEE REVIEW.
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL ENSURES
THAT IF THAT OCCURS THAT THOSE
SAME LABOR PROTECTIONS THAT I
JUST DISCUSSED WOULD BE APPLIED
SO THAT THERE BE SOME PROTECTION
FOR THE WORKERS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD --
ORIGIN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OFFICIALLY IN SUPPORT -- TWO
THREE MINUTES OKAY.
UP AND I'M NOTING THE OVERALL
TIME OF PRESENTATION WILL.
A REVITALIZATION FOR SIMILAR --
OPPORTUNITY.
GOOD AFTERNOON HOURS JACKSON
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL.
LIKE MANY CALIFORNIANS IN MY OWN
FAMILY STORIES TIED UP WITH THIS
BILL MY GRANDFATHER WAS
EVACUATED FROM THE CAMPFIRE AND
THANKFULLY HIS LIFE WAS SPARED
THAT DAY BUT I DO THINK IT MAY
ACOSTA SPIRIT.
HE DIED SHORTLY THEREAFTER IN AN
ERROR BEING BI AND YUBA CITY.
BUT I WANT TO ELIMINATE TODAY
THE IMPACT.
THIS BILL HAS ON A CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS ANOTHER DIMENSION THAT I
THINK IT'S LOST AMONG THE OTHER
COMPETING VALID CONCERNS WITH
THIS ISSUE.
WE CANNOT MAKE GOOD ON OUR CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS IF OUR MAJOR.
INVESTORS IN CLEAN ENERGY ARE ON
THE BRINK OF INSOLVENCY OR IN
BANKRUPTCY.
OR I FOR ASKING CUSTOMERS TO
SHOULDER THE BURDEN.
OF THESE COSTS.
SO ULTIMATELY WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON REDUCING THE UNDERLYING RISK
AND THE UNDERLYING COSTS AND NOT
JUST SOCIALIZE THEM MORE
EQUITABLY.
BUT WE NEED A BRIDGE TO GET
THERE WE THINK THIS BILL GETS
THE BALANCING ACT RIGHT IT
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT
PARADIGM SHIFT TO OCCUR. FOR
THAT REASON WE ASK THE AYE VOTE
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CHANCE
MONEY JONES WITH THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT. TEN FIFTY
FOUR A. AS HOPEFULLY STABILIZING
THE FINANCIAL MARKET HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- MY MEMBER
COMPANIES HAVE IT AND OTHERS
HAVE INVESTED LITERALLY TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE HERE MODERNIZE IN
OUR FLEET RELIABILITY RESOURCES
AND HEADED OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF RENEWABLE RESOURCES --
THE GREAT PROGRESS MEETING THEIR
GOALS AND AND OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS HAVE BEEN REDUCED TO
THAT NIGHT 30% LESS THAN THAT
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS HUGE
SUCCESS.
THAT'S ALL IN DANGER THE
CONTRACTS THAT ARE A BIT A
EXECUTE OUR IN OUR WITH THESE
UTILITIES HAVE BEEN DANGER.
P. GENIES IN BANKRUPTCY OTHER TO
UTILITIES BORDERING ON JUNK BOND
STATUS -- THAT HAS A REAL COST
TO CALIFORNIA -- RATE PAYERS AND
IT HAS A REAL COST TO GOING
FORWARD I THINK YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD THAT THAT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES A LOT OF THE INHERENT
SAFETY QUESTIONS WHICH IS
SPECIFICALLY AROUND WHAT PRUDENT --
MANAGER MEANS THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY A SAFETY CERTIFICATE
GIVEN -- ADDRESSING THAT FIRE
LIABILITY WILL GO A LONG WAY I
BELIEVE IN STABILIZING THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS AND GAIN IS
BACK ON TRACK WE CAN GENERALLY
THIS IS A GOOD BILL.
I WANT TO SAY THIS IS A GREAT
TESTAMENT -- TO SORT OF
BIPARTISAN WORK OF TRYING TO
SOLVE -- AID A NUMBER OF INTER
RELATED VERY DIFFICULT PROBLEMS
AND I THINK THIS IS A GUY A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
GOVERNMENT WORKING FOR THE THE
BENEFIT OF ITS CITIZENS AND I
WOULD URGE -- AND I BOUGHT A TEN
FOOT FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- THOSE IN SUPPORT
NAME POSITION PLEASE AND WILL
MOVE THROUGH IT QUICKLY AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE THE OPPOSITION.
KERRY HAD A BIKE NEXTERA ENERGY
RESOURCES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KELLY BOYD CALIFORNIA LOW CARBON
FUEL AND ENERGY COALITION IN
SUPPORT. TOO MANY HUNTER FOR THE
SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION OF THE LARGE SCALE
SOLAR ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AT JULIE MALINOVSKY BOBBY HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA BY A MASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
IN THE MODERN HAVE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER THIRTY
IT'S PART.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES CESSATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT WE HAVE NOTED
TODAY FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IN AUTHOR STAFF SOME CONCERNS
WITH NEW LANGUAGE ADDED TO THE
BILL ON FRIDAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTEZ ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LAND TROUT
NON BEHALF OF CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE AMERICAN
WHEN ANDERSON ENERGY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATT BROAD FOR THE ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIA I HAVE
P. T. LOCAL TWENTY WE REPRESENT --
FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS AT P.
JEANNIE THANK YOU AND SUPPORT.
HI MEREDITH STAPLES WITH ESC
LOCAL -- TWENTY I HAVE P. T..
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JONATHAN RIGHT
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIA LOCAL TWENTY I HAVE
PT REPRESENTING A THOUSAND
PROFESSIONALS FROM EUREKA
BAKERSFIELD INCLUDING FOUR
THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL ENGINEERS.
AT PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC.
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY GILSON IT'S
A POOR ON BEHALF OF THE OFFICIAL
CREDITORS COMMITTEE APPOINTED BY
THE US GOVERNMENT. TO REPRESENT
THE INTEREST OF THOSE WITH
CLAIMS AGAINST P. JEANNIE
INCLUDING TENS AND THOUSANDS OF
UNION MEMBERS AND RETIREES
RENEWABLE ENERGY PROVIDERS VITAL
ANDERSON SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
LITERALLY DO THE WORK TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON THANK YOU.
KYLE GRIFFITH ON BEHALF OF THE
ACTION FOR WILDFIRE RESILIENCY
COALITION -- WITH A COALITION
LETTER OF MORE THAN SIXTY
ORGANIZATIONS FROM LABOR
BUSINESS COMMUNITY SENIOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS ARE URGING
SUPPORT FOR TEN FIFTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
CARE MARIN SENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL YOUR
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO THE
CITY'S VERY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE THE EFFORTS TO LEGISLATURE'S
EFFORTS IN THIS AREA THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS.
THERE BEEN SOME CONVERSATIONS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED THIS WEEKEND
SOME OF THE FINER POINTS OF THE
BILL -- THE CITY'S VERY
APPRECIATIVE -- OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S -- ENGAGEMENT
ON THAT AND LOOK FOR THE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BEING ON GOING
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER THANK YOU.
MARK JOSEPH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JOHNSON PRESS THE IBEW LOCAL
TWELVE FORTY FIVE WE ALL SUPPORT.
RUTH BAILEY ARE RETIRED P. GINNY
THIRTY YEARS TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
LOCAL TWELVE FORTY FIVE SHOP
STEWARD STRONG SUPPORT.
A PAUL GALLON RETIRED FUJIANESE
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL.
FRED ROSS ORGANIZER I MEAN HAVE
YOU TWO OH FORTY FIVE STRONG
SUPPORT.
KRISTIN RASMUSON IBEW LOCAL
TWELVE FORTY FIVE STRONG SUPPORT.
DANA JOHNSON I'D BE A W. TOLL
FREE FIVE STRONG SUPPORT.
HI CINNAMON STAFFORD A. B. E. W.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE IN SUPPORT.
KEVIN CHROMIS IBEW TOLL FORTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY
STEP MOM MOLLY MURPHY WHO LOST
HER HOME IN SANTA ROSA AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
SHANNON SPACE TWELVE FORTY FIVE
MEMBER IBEW STRONG SUPPORT.
AS HE IS MAN I BE THE VETO FORTY
FIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JAMES I SURE WOULD -- TWELVE
FORTY FIVE AND MY WIFE AND I
LIVE IN A FIRE I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT BILL STRONG SUPPORT.
WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS GREG COOK
RIVER THEY KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY AND GOLDEN STATE
POWER COOPERATIVE IN SUPPORT.
THE LOPEZ IBEW TWELVE FORTY FIVE
IN SUPPORT -- AS A WORKER UP AT
THE HIGHWAY -- TWELVE CINEMA --
OUT OF THIS FIRE AND I'VE BEEN
UP THERE FOR A FEW WEEKS AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU.
PHILIP DORY IBEW TOLL FORTY FIVE
STRONG SUPPORT.
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
TREE CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
XANDER GOFF WITH CALPINE COMING
FROM THE HALLWAY BECAUSE YOU
HAVE SO MANY SUPPORTERS BUT ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
JOHN WHITE WITH THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
HI MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IF
THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE TIME --
PERSONALLY I REPRESENTING CLICK
A CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS.
OUR TWEENER WERE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL -- THERE COUPLE COMMENTS
I'D LIKE TO TO SHARE THE
COMMITTEE OUT I'LL BE BRIEF ONE
IS I THINK EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
RATES ARE GOING UP -- AND THEY
WOULD HAVE GONE UP WITHOUT THIS
BILL -- AND SO THE STATUS QUO IS
UNTENABLE AND SO I THINK A LOT
OF CREDIT DOES NEED TO GO TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE AUTHORS
OF THIS BILL -- TRYING TO MANAGE
A VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION.
HOWEVER LARGE ENERGY CONSUMERS
THAT TAKE THEIR POWER A
TRANSMISSION LEVELS BECAUSE OF
THE EQUAL CENTS PER KILOWATT
BASIS ALLOCATION OF THE COSTS OF
THE SURCHARGE.
WILL BEAR THE LARGEST BURDEN
HAVE THE RATE INCREASE.
AND SO WE THINK THERE ARE MANY
COMMON SENSE APPROACHES THAT
COULD BE DEALT WITH BY THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATORS IN
GIVING US RATE RELIEF IN OTHER
AREAS AND SO THIS IS WHERE THE
BILL'S DEFICIENT.
AND DOESN'T ALLOW US TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY BUT WE LOOK FOR FOR
THAT CONVERSATION MR HOLDEN I'VE
HAD THIS CONVERSATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A CONTINUED
CONVERSATION WITH MR MAYES MISS
BURKE -- MOVING FORWARD SO THANK
YOU FOR INDULGENCE.
THANK YOU I JUST -- WE'RE GONNA.
THIS IS FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
WIENER.
WINNERS WILL HAVE A A PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY -- WE'RE GONNA DO
THE OPPOSITION AND THEN WINTERS
IN A PROCEDURE TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WE FINISHED WITH SUPPORT.
OKAY WILL HAVE THE TWO WINNERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AND MICHAEL BOOKER ON
BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION.
LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING THE
AUTHOR CO AUTHORS AND GOVERNOR
STAFF FOR FINDING A SWEET SPOT
IN A TERRIBLY DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
WELL WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL -- WE DO
BELIEVE IT'S A VAST IMPROVEMENT
OVER SB NINE A WANT FOR SHE'S
MADE A YEAH SB NOT A ONE AND
WILL LIMIT RATE PAYER IMPACTS
AND HOPE THAT THE BILL MOVES TO
THE GOVERNOR AND HIS PAST -- WE
DO HAVE SOME HESITATION IS AND
IT'S THE NEW SURCHARGE IS BEING
CREATED AND AS YOU JUST HEARD
FROM OUR LARGE INDUSTRIAL
CUSTOMERS WE HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS.
AND JUST WE PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE FOR SOME OF OUR
LARGE FOOD PROCESSING CUSTOMERS.
THE NEW SURCHARGE WILL ADD FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR TO THEIR ELECTRICITY BILL.
THAT SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT FIFTEEN
YEARS AND IF THAT WAS THE END OF
IT.
IT WOULD BE A GOOD CONVERSATION
IT'S NOT WE'RE ALSO PAYING FORCE
SYSTEM HARDENING WILD FIRE
MITIGATIONCOSTS ARE GOING TO
ADD LITERALLY.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
EACH OF THOSE COMPANIES OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR THOSE
COMPANIES TO CONTINUE TO BE
COMPETITIVE UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH MISS BURKE MR HOLDEN AND
MISTER MAYES AS WE MOVE FORWARD
TO HOPEFULLY FIND WAYS TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THOSE IMPACTS.
THAT THEY COULD EASILY BE THREE
TO FIVE CENTS A KILOWATT HOUR
ADDITIONALLY PARTICULAR
IMPEACHING YOU SERVICE TERRITORY --
WE KNOW THE CO AUTHORS AND
AUTHORS FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT --
WE ALSO REMAIN CONCERNED ENSURE
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE EXPRESSED
BY THE LOBBYIST FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO -- THERE
ARE SOME AND NEW MUNICIPALITY
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED BY
THE LAST -- RECENT AMENDMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO
GET THOSE CORRECTED AS WE MOVE
pFORWARD THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRIDGE THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTRAC PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA DAIRY
ZINC AMERICAN PISTACHIO GROWERS
AND OTHER AGRICULTURAL TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS.
ALSO NEUTRAL ON THE BILL --
SHARING SOME OF THE CONCERNS --
THAT WERE SHARED BY THE OTHER
WINNERS -- THAT NEW SURCHARGE
EXPRESSLY WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT AGRICULTURE AND IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IN OTHER AREAS
THAT ARE IN THOSE HIGH FIRE
RISKS AND HAVING TO PAY THOSE
COSTS -- AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
PASS ON THOSE COSTS TO CONSUMERS
AS OTHERS MAY BE ABLE TO DO.
AND EXPRESSLY WITH THOSE
CONTINUAL RATE INCREASES THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY IS
CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE THEIR
ENERGY COSTS ARE GOING BUT AGAIN
WE THINK THE AUTHORS OF THE BILL
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
WORKING WITH US AND ALSO HAVING
THAT DIALOGUE ABOUT WHAT ELSE WE
CAN DO. TO LOWER RATES OR TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT -- TO OUR
AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS AND
GROWERS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE LEGACY
OF FOR THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE STATE'S.
TRANSPORTATION FUEL SUPPLIERS
REFINERS AND OIL PRODUCERS.
ALSO HAPPEN TO BE SIMILAR TO THE
LARGEST ENERGY USERS IN BOTH
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS THE UNIFICATION IMPACT
IN RATES BUT WE UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION WE'RE IN.
WE KNOW WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER.
SO WE WANT TO BE CONSTRUCTIVE.
WE WANT TO BE HELPFUL SO WE'RE
TAKING A NEUTRAL POSITION BUT WE
DO FEEL COMPELLED TO TELL YOU
THAT WERE VERY VERY MUCH
CONCERNED NOT.
JUST ABOUT THE RATE THAT THE
POTENTIAL OF EMERGENCY SHUT
DOWNS THE ENERGY STATION.
JUST AS WERE BEING TOLD TODAY
THAT WE HAVE TO ACCEPT
SIGNIFICANT RATE INCREASES WERE
BEING NOTIFIED BY THE UTILITIES
IN OUR REFINERIES AND ON OIL
PRODUCTION FIELDS.
THAT WE HAVE TO BRACE OURSELVES
FOR EMERGENCY SHUTDOWNS.
THAT'S AN UNTENABLE COMBINATION.
ON RELIABLE POWER MORE EXPENSIVE
POWER.
SO AS YOU FINALIZE THIS PACKAGE
OF LEGISLATION.
AND HOPEFULLY PROVIDE MORE --
MORE SECURITY FOR THE UTILITIES
AND FOR THE MARKETS WE HOPE
YOU'LL TURN YOUR ATTENTION TO
WHAT WE DO ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
SHUT DOWNS.
AND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD FROM
HERE WE LOOK FOR TO TALKING AND
WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT POINT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AT THE
BOOKSTORE BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT
THE POLICY ISSUES THAT ARE OF
CONCERN TO MANUFACTURERS OF ALL
SIZES WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE
TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
BUT I DID WANT TO GET ON THE
RECORD -- IS CMJ IS NEUTRAL IN
THE LEGISLATION OVER VERY
SUPPORT OF THE EFFORTS OF MR
HOLDEN.
MS BURKE IN MISTER MAYES THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND ALL THE
NATIONS THAT THEY'VE HAD WITH US
MANUFACTURERS THROUGHOUT THE
MANY MONTHS AND WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE'S SOME
CONFUSION ON SUPPORT WE HAVE A A
VICTIM AND NORTH A FIRE VICTIMS
WHICH IS LIKE THIRTY SECONDS TO
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT.
WELL THIRTY SECONDS PLEASE.
AND LET'S STIPULATE YOU'RE
REPRESENTING THE VICTIMS IN
GENERAL.
YES SIR PLEASE THIRTY SECONDS.
MY NAME IS JOHN DEAVER'S WE LOST
FAMILY THE NIGHT OF THE NORTH
BAY FIRES SHE CALLED FROM
TRAPPED WITHIN HER HOME.
AND WE HAD TO LISTEN.
HER LAST WORDS WERE I'M GOING TO
DIE IN THAT SHE STARTED TO
SCREAM AND THEN THE PHONE CALL
CUT OFF.
I TELL YOU THE STORY YES I ALSO
WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND.
THE VICTIMIZATION DID NOT END
WITH THE EXTINGUISHING OF THE
FLAMES.
THEY CONTINUE THEY PERSIST AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES WHAT TEN
FIFTY FOUR DOES HIS AT LEAST IT
BEGINS THE START OF ADDRESSING
THOSE SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
IF I HAVE THE COURAGE TO COME
HERE AND TELL YOU THE STORY I
HOPE YOU HAVE THE COURAGE TO
VOTE FOR THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF THOSE IN OPPOSITION
NEXT PLEASE.
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION PLEASE. TO
THE TO THE DESK HERE AND WE'RE
GOING TO TRY.
TO GIVE YOU ANY AT SORT OF AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR TIME WE
DON'T WANT TO GO IN EXCESS OF
PROBABLY. EIGHT MINUTES TOTAL I
THINK WE HAD ABOUT.
EIGHT TO TEN WITH THE WITH THE
ARE GOOD SUPPORT.
AND WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA BE
BE GENEROUS WITH THE CLOCK THANK
YOU COULD I GET YOUR YOUR POINT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM PLAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
NO ONE HERE REALLY KNOWS WHO I
AM.
I AM A UC BERKELEY GRADUATE FROM
LAW SCHOOL -- I'M A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR IN THE
ORGANIZED CRIME FIELD.
I WAS AN ASSISTANT COUNSEL TO
THE UNITED STATES SENATE
PERMANENT SUBCOMMITTEE ON
INVESTIGATIONS DOING OVERSIGHT.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE I
BECAME AN ATTORNEY.
FOR THE CUSTOMERS OF SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC WHEN THEY ATTEMPTED
TO RECOVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT.
EXCEEDED WHAT THEY HAD I HAVE
COVERED WITH YOUR INSURANCE IN
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN FIRES.
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THAT
LITIGATION EVER SENSE.
BUT WAS PART OF THE TEAM THAT
TRIED THE CASE.
IN JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN
WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO SHOW.
THAT S. TGT WAS NOT PRUDENT AND
STARTING THE FIRES I'VE NEVER
RECEIVED A PENNY AND NOT BEING
PAID I HAVEN'T CHARGED FOR THE
PERIOD OF TIME THAT I HAVE.
ATTEMPTED TO REPRESENT UTILITY
CUSTOMERS I WILL BE BRIEF AND
FOCUSED [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ONE THE CHANGE IN THE PERMANENCY
ROLE.
THE DISCUSSION ON THE PRUDENT TO
ROLL I THINK HAS BEEN SOMEWHAT
UNINFORMED BY ALL OF US.
THE REAL CHANGE IS NOT ABOUT THE
BURDEN OF PROOF.
THE REAL CHANGE IS ABOUT WHETHER
THE PRINCE WHO RULED.
WILL BE PRUDENCE IN THE SENSE
THAT THE UTILITY WAS PRUDENT
WHEN THEY SETTLED THE CASE.
AND THEREFORE THAT SATISFIES THE
PRINCE TO RULE.
OR WILL IT BE PRUDENCE IN THE
SENSE THAT THEY WILL BE ASSESSED
IN WHETHER THEY WERE PRUDENT AND
THE WAY THAT THEY MAINTAINED AND
OPERATED THEIR SYSTEM.
NOW YOU MIGHT THINK WELL YOU
KNOW HOW COULD I MAKE SUCH A
STATEMENT BUT OF CURRENTLY.
WE ARE BEFORE THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT ALL THE UTILITIES
ON THIS ISSUE OR BEFORE THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
SDG AN A IN THEIR FILING ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THEIR PETITION FOR CERT.
SAID IN REFERRING TO FOR THAT
FIRST HELD THAT RECOVERY.
OF WILDFIRE COSTS.
WAS WARRANTED WITHOUT REGARD TO
THE PRUDENCE OF ESTY GENIES
MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS.
THAT THE WORDS SDG NAY OF THE
UTILITIES TAKE THE POSITION.
THAT.
GOOD NEWS AS TO HOW THEY WERE
OPERATING FACILITIES.
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
REQUIRED FOR THEM TO SHOW.
IN THE CURRENT BILL IF YOU LOOK
AT THE CURRENT BILL SECTION.
SIX AND YOU LOOK DOWN AND YOU
READ.
IT'S THE TALKS ABOUT ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS CONDUCT.
NOW THE WORDS THE PRUDENCE
EQUATION.
FOCUSES ON THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS CONDUCT IT DOESN'T
SAY CONDUCT IN CONNECTION WITH
ITS ROLE IN IGNITING THE FIRE
AND IF YOU NOTICE AT ANOTHER
LOCATION IN THE BILL.
THEY TALK ABOUT IT NATION.
BUT HERE THEY TALK ABOUT CONDUCT
SO ONE CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CLARIFICATION IN THE BILL.
NUMBER TWO YOU CAN NOT AT THE
LEGISLATIVE LEVEL EXTEND THE
SURCHARGE WHICH WAS IMPLEMENTED
TO COVER.
THE MANIPULATED PRICES BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE THAT WAS
THE CPUC PROCEEDING YOU CAN YOU
CAN ENTITLE THE CPUC. TO START A
PROCEEDING TO DO THE EXTENSION.
BUT THE RATE PAYERS HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT PROCESS BECAUSE YOU'RE
SETTING RATES.
IF YOU DON'T DO THAT THEN THAT
WOULD BE IN MY JUDGMENT TO BE
CONSIDERED A TAKING.
LAST POINT.
ALL FOCUS SHOULD BE ON STOPPING
THE WILD FIRES PERIOD.
IF YOU READ THIS LOSS AND OR IF
YOU READ THE WALL STREET JOURNAL
TODAY.
THERE'S A DEVASTATING FRONT PAGE
STORY THAT MAKES THE CASE.
THAT P. JEANNIE HAS KNOWN FOR A
LONG TIME AND HAS IGNORED THE
FACT.
THAT THEIR POWER LINES ARE IN
HORRIBLE SHAPE.
THAT THEY ARE OUTMODED AND THEY
NEEDED TO BE REPAIRED AT THE
FRONT PAGE STORY IN THE WALL
STREET JOURNAL.
MY SUGGESTION.
AN ALTERNATIVE SUGGESTION.
IS THAT YOUR COMMITTEE DEVELOP.
VERY PRECISE FACTUAL
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT BREAKDOWNS
IN THE MANAGEMENT AT THE
UTILITIES.
WHAT BREAKDOWN ACTUALLY RESULTED
IN THE CAUSING OF FIRES?
AND THAT YOU ADDRESS THOSE
MANAGEMENT SHORTFALLS WITH VERY
SPECIFIC.
NEW RULES NUMBER TWO THE TO
EXPAND THE EXISTING SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT AT CEBU CITY THEY
HAVE GREAT PEOPLE.
IN SAFETY ENFORCEMENT AT CPUC.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE EXPANDED
STATUS.
THEY DON'T HAVE MONEY.
YOU DON'T NEED ANY MORE RULES.
GENERAL ORDER NINETY FIVE IS A
VERY PRECISE SET OF RULES THAT
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED
PAINSTAKINGLY BY THE CPUC SINCE.
NINETEEN THIRTEEN THEY ARE VERY
PRECISE WHEN WE WHEN WE SHOW
THAT SDG ESTY GINNY DID NOT.
ACT PRUDENTLY WE DID THAT BY
SHOWING THEY SPECIFICALLY
VIOLATED PRECISE PROVISIONS OF
GENERAL ORDER.
NINETY FIVE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
NOW CLOSE HERE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH THIS BILL.
IS YOUR GIVING ALL THE
INCENTIVES TO HAVE MORE WILD
FIRES.
MY ESTIMATED YOU'RE TALKING
BETWEEN 200-252-20050 BILLION
DOLLARS.
OF MORE WILDFIRE COSTS WHICH
WILL AUTOMATICALLY BE BECOME AN
OBLIGATION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE ROLLED INTO
BONDS THE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
WILL BE REQUIRED TO STAND BEHIND.
AND THAT WILL BRING INTO
QUESTION JUST LIKE IT DID BEFORE.
THE CREDIT RATING OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SO MY SUGGESTION TO USE I THINK
EVERYONE HERE IS WELL INTENDED.
I THINK EVERYONE HERE IS TRYING
HIS HARDEST A CAN GOVERNOR
EVERYBODY ELSE.
BUT I I I JUST ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THE PERSPECTIVE OF
SOMEONE WHO'S WORKED ON THIS
ISSUE FOR TEN YEARS.
HAND TO HAND COMBAT WITH THESE
FABULOUS UTILITIES AND THEIR
FABULOUS LAWYERS.
AND I'M TELLING YOU PLEASE DO
NOT PASS THIS BILL PLEASE TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT YOUR APPROACH
AND ASK THE GOVERNOR TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AND START BY
READING THE THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL ARTICLE IN THE PAPER
TODAY.
AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible] THREE MINUTES.
BOOK AND WE'LL GET TO ABOUT NINE
OR TEN MINUTES I WANT TO BE AS
FAIR AS I CAN FOR BOTH SIDES --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MY NAME
IS WILLIAM ABRAMS -- I'M A
WILDFIRE SURVIVOR FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OR BIG WILD
FIRES - I AM HERE TODAY TO
ARGUE AGAINST MY SHORT TERM
INTERESTS -- FOR THE LONGER TERM
INTERESTS OF OUR STATE AND OUR
CITIZENS -- WE RAN FROM THE
FIRES WITH MY TWO YOUNG KIDS
UNDER MY ARMS AND BY ALL MEANS
I'M WITH MY COMMUNITY WHO IS IN
NEED OF MONEY IN COMPENSATION TO
HELP US ALONG THE RECOVERY PATH --
BUT AS THE FOLKS IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL SPOKE -- TO THAT THIS
REALLY IS -- PROVIDING SOME
MAJOR LEERAGE WITH P. JEANNIE.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHERE THERE'S
SOME ALIGNMENT WITH THE FOLKS
WHO NEED HELP NOW.
LIKE ME.
ALONG WITH THE UTILITY INTERESTS
WHO WANT A LITTLE LESS
REGULATION AND A LITTLE LESS
ACCOUNTABILITY INTO THE FUTURE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY I AM ALSO --
THE PARTY TO THE CPC PROCEEDINGS
SO -- I HAVE SORT OF THAT
PERSPECTIVE IN HADN'T I HAD THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
I WOULD HAVE LOOKED AT THIS BILL.
IN A VERY SHORT TIME THAT YOU OF
ALL HAD TO CONSIDER IT.
AND I WOULD HAVE BEEN RUSHED
ALONG WITH SOME OF THE LOBBYIST
TO KNOCK ON MY DOOR TO SAY COME
ON THIS IS GREAT FOR YOU I KNOW
YOU NEED THE MONEY PLEASE LINE
UP AND AND COLLECT.
AND I WOULD HAVE BEEN RIGHT
ALONG WITH THEM HOWEVER.
THROUGH MY WORK AT THE SHEEP YOU
SEE I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
TRADE OFFS.
SO RIGHT NOW IN THE CPUC.
THERE ARE PROCEEDINGS THERE ARE
PLANS THERE ARE THINGS THAT WILL
BE PUSHED ASIDE TO MAKE ROOM FOR
THIS BILL.
HERE'S WHAT WE DON'T HAVE TIME
TO CONSIDER NEITHER YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
ARE YOU SITTING AT THE DESK TWO
MINUTES.
SOME HERE WE GO THANK AND THIS
IS EXACTLY ISSUE THIS IS AND I I
APPRECIATE I BELIEVE ME I
APPRECIATE THE RUB HERE BUT THIS
IS THE ISSUE IS THAT EVERYBODY
HAS TO RUSH THROUGH A VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS.
THAT REQUIRE ANALYSIS WHAT I
SUGGEST YOU DO IS HOLD UP.
THE NEXT PHASE OF THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS THAT ARE BEFORE
THIS IF YOU SEE AND LOOK AT
THESE PLANTS THROUGH THE BILL.
LESS OVERSIGHT LESS
ACCOUNTABILITY CURRENTLY WITH
THE CPU SEE THEY'VE ALREADY
GOTTEN TO THE POINT OF SAYING
HEY WE NEED TO HAVE PERFORMANCE
BASED METRICS.
TIGHTER FINANCIALS.
I WANT TO SUPPORT A CREDIT
RATING FOR THE UTILITIES BUT
THEY'VE GOT TO EARN IT.
NOT THIS GIVEAWAY THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO ARTIFICIALLY PROP UP
THEIR CREDIT RATING I WANT THEM
TO WORK TO WORK TOWARDS IT BY
MITIGATING FIRE RISKS.
THIS PROVIDES THEM WITH THE
ABILITY TO BACK AWAY FROM THEIR
SAFETY.
THIS PROVIDES THEM ABILITY TO
TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO SPEND AS MUCH
TIME ON MITIGATION WE'VE GOT
THIS FUND WHICH WILL RUN OUT IN
ABOUT A SUMMER.
AND THEN MORE OR WILL ALL OF US
BE.
AND THIS IS THE PROBLEM THE
PROBLEM IS NONE OF US HAVE TIME
TO GO THROUGH THIS HOLD UP
WHAT'S PRESENT BY THE WAY.
ALL THE SAFETY [inaudible]
ORGANIZATIONS.
BETTER BEFORE THE CPUC THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THIS FIELD. FOR TEN PLUS
YEARS.
HAVE ALL SAID THAT THIS IS A BAD
BILL.
THOSE ARE THE FOLKS THAT I TURN
TO BECAUSE I'M NEW TO THIS AS OF
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN SO I TRIED TO DO MY
DUE DILIGENCE AND REACH OUT TO
ALL THE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
WHO KNEW MORE THAN I I'VE SPOKEN
TO THE PEOPLE WHO WERE THE
AUTHORS.
OF THIS BILL.
I SPOKE TO THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
AND THEY DID NOT MAKE THOSE
CALLS SPEAK TO THE PEOPLE AT THE
SAFETY DEPARTMENT AT THE CPUC
ASKED THEM YOU'RE ADDING THREE
MORE LAYERS OF BUREAUCRACY.
IS THAT A HELP TO YOU.
HOW DOES THIS FIT IN TO ASK YOU
SOME A PLEASE?
ENTER IT DID MY EFFORT HERE IS
TO BE FAIR FOR BOTH SIDES WITH
RESPECT TO THE TIME ALLOTTED AYE
AYE UNDER AND I AND AND I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH IT
AND I UNDERSTAND HOW I'M DOING
MY VERY BEST -- I'M WHAT I'M
ASKING FOR SUMMATION ABOUT
THIRTY SECONDS THIRTY SECONDS
CLOSE THIRTY SECOND SUMMATION
THERE ARE LOOPHOLES THAT THE
ATTORNEYS WILL DRIVE TRUCKS
THROUGH TO GET THIS THROUGH.
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF REGULATIONS
THAT DON'T BELONG HERE I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURE ON ALL
OF YOU AND ON ME. TO SUPPORT
THIS.
I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS SURGERY
NOT TO SUPPORT THIS.
I KNOW I'M A DEMOCRAT I WANT TO
GET BEHIND IT.
I FULLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR AND
ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS BUT THIS IS
NOT IT THIS PUT YOUR ALL IN
JEOPARDY FOR THE LONG TERM FOR
SHORT TERM PAY OUTS.
AND SHORT TERM.
THINGS TO HOLD UP THE I. O. U.'S
IN GET THEM DISINCENTIVE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU PUSH IT UP.
OTHERS HERE YET THAT WANT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION -- PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL.
I AGREE WITH THE LAST SPEAKER I
WAS KEPT THINKING MA'AM I HAVE --
TO KAREN PERKINS I'M CENTER AND
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
MY PRISON NO MORE I OPPOSE
OPPOSE THE BILL.
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE
THE VAST FORTY MILLION AFTER ALL
I HAVE TO ARE NOT HERE.
AND AND THIS IS BEING RUSHED
THROUGH ITS BEING RUSHED THROUGH
SAM ASKED AND IT WILL BE ALL
PRIVATIZING PROFITS AND
SOCIALISING LOSSES WITH.
NO INCENTIVE WHATSOEVER FOR THEM
TO CHECK THEIR POWER LIGHT.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTAND THESE ARE RULES OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THEY ARE EMINENTLY FAIR AND WE
ASK FOR THOSE TO PARTICIPATE
WITH IN THOSE RULES THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
SEEING NONE WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT UP -- BACK GUY HERE -- I WHAT
BUT DO WE HAVE I THINK WE SHOULD
PROBABLY HAVE SOME OPPORTUNITY.
FOR QUESTIONS THE AT SOME POINT
I'M GONNA WANT TO ASK -- FOR
SOME RESPONSES -- WITH REGARD TO
WHAT TESTIMONY WE'VE HEARD IF
MEMBERS WANT TO QUESTION THAT.
AND OPEN THAT UP I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE LET'S
LET'S OPEN THIS TO TO MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS.
OUR WHO FIRST.
THE NEW ARMS CUNNINGHAM THAN MR
MESSAGES.
SO I THANK YOU ALLALL THREE OF
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS BEEN A
MONTHS LONG PROCESS OF
DELIBERATION STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS.
AS I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE FOR THE PUBLIC DOMAIN I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS IT
PROTECTS THE WORKERS WHICH I
THINK IS AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
I THINK IT STABILIZES THE I. O.
U.'S WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT THING
TO DO AT THIS POINT -- AND THIS
JUNCTURE AND WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
MAKE THE BEST OF A BAD SITUATION
THAT NONE OF US.
BECAUSE THEN I THINK THIS IS A
VALIANT EFFORT I WANTED TO FOCUS
A LITTLE BIT ON AND AND GET THE
AUTHORS.
RESPONSES ON SOME POINTS RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION WITH RESPECT --
TO THE WHAT I BELIEVE IS CALLED
THE PRUDENT MANAGER STANDARD AND
HOW THAT WORKS WITH THE BILL
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING
[inaudible]
IS THAT.
FINALLY WE HAVE A BIG INCENTIVE
PROBLEM WITH THE I'VE USE
BECAUSE OF WEATHER AND I WOULD.
PASCAL LOOKED THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL A EITHER YESTERDAY OR
TODAY THAT SAID PEACHY NEEDS.
UNDER INVESTED IN SAFETY.
IN A BIG WAY AND THAT'S THE
WALLSTREET JOURNAL.
OKAY SO WHEN THESE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES HAPPENING AND AND
COULD TAKE LIVES AND PROPERTY IN
COST US ALL.
COST BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THOSE
THOSE IMMEDIATELY PUSHED I OWE
YOU ANY GIVEN I'LL YOU P.
JEANNIE OR ANYBODY.
IN THE INSOLVENCY.
SO WE'VE GOT TO CREATE A PATH TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
INCENTIVIZE TO INVEST IN
HARDENING THE SYSTEM AND I THINK
THIS BILL DOES THAT AND I THINK
THE WAY IT DOES IT.
IS BY SAYING THAT.
YOU HAVE TO GET A SAFETY
CERTIFICATION AND THEN YOU HAVE
A PRESUMPTION THAT COULD
PRESUMPTION CAN BE OVERCOME --
THROUGH THE PROCEEDINGS BUT YOU
HAVE A PRESUMPTION.
SO IT IT CREATES AN INCENTIVE
STRUCTURE IN A FUNDING MECHANISM
TO MAKE SURE THE I USE ARE
INVESTING IN SAFETY FIRST AND
MAKE SURE THEY'RE CHANGING THEIR
INTERNAL CULTURES.
SO THAT THEY TAKE A SAFETY FIRST
MENTALITY AND OUT HOW THEY
ALLOCATE THE RESOURCES THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE BILL.
I WOULD WELCOME ANY OF THE
AUTHORS OF LIKE TO EXPOUND UPON --
I WOULD START WITH YES THOSE
THOSE THINGS ARE IN PLACE AND
THERE'S A CERTIFICATION IN PLACE
BUT THERE IS ALSO BEFORE THAT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
AGGREGATE THAT HAS TO GO TO
INFRASTRUCTURE FIRE SAFETY
MEDICATION IS GONNA REMIND
QUICKLY THROUGH THE CHAIR.
THROUGH THE CHAIRS.
ACCORDING TO THE RULES THROUGH
THE CHAIR.
WHAT I JUST SAID -- AND ON THAT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO EARN A RATE OF RETURN.
OR PROFIT FROM THAT INVESTMENT
SO I MEAN THAT'S AN INITIAL
HARDENING -- OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FIRE SAFETY
THAT STARTS THAT IS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FUND AT ALL --
AND THEN YOU HAVE YOUR YOUR
YEARLY CERTIFICATIONS AND I
WOULD SAY TO THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL AS IS.
THIS YEAR THE CPUC HAS DONE THE
BEST THEY CAN HOWEVER ON THE NEW
BOARD AND DIVISIONS WILL HAVE
FIRE EXPERTS PEOPLE THAT HAVE
OVER THE YEARS.
BUILT IN EXPERTISE IN FIRE
MANAGEMENT EMPIRE SAFETY WITH
UTILITIES I THINK THAT EXPERTISE
IS VERY IMPORTANT AND BECAUSE
IT'S OUTSIDE OF THE A PC THERE
WILL BE MORE NIMBLE TO ALL NEW.
NEW SITUATIONS THAT ARISE AND
ADJUSTING THE WHAT IS REQUIRED
FOR THOSE CERTIFICATIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE ALWAYS AT THE
HEIGHT OF WHAT IS AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY WISE MAY I PLEASE
RESPOND.
WE ARE UP IN THE MEMBER UP. TO
HIS QUESTION THAT'S ALL I KNOW I
DID MEMBERS ARE NOW -- ABLE TO
ASK QUESTIONS OTHER MEMBERS MAY
WANT TO OPEN UP THE DISCARDED
AND REALIZED THAT HE WAS ONLY
ASKING ONE SIDE.
QUESTION NOT THAT OKAY PLEASE
ONE SEC ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT I'M
GONNA HAVE TO JUST LOOK THIS IS
THROUGH THE CHAIR OKAY I AND
IT'S WHICH BUT WITH RESPECT. TO
THE PRACTICED RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT OKAY HERE AND WE ARE
NOW AT A POINT WHERE MEMBERS ARE
QUESTIONING AND THEY WILL
CONTROL WHO THEY TALKED TO IN
THE QUESTIONS THAT THEY ASK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS -- FOR MS MOTORCYCLES
STANDING THAT.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE LARGELY
THROUGH THE WORK OF A ATTORNEYS
WITH O'MELVENY MYERS AND
GOVERNMENT GUGGENHEIM INVESTORS --
BASICALLY WROTE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
WITH.
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH OUR
VISORS WORK CLOSELY WITH -- THE
AUTHORS OF LEGISLATIVE STUFF AND
DEVELOPING THAT LEGISLATION I
WAS TOLD THAT -- THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE SENT LANGUAGE. TO THE
AUTHORS ON FRIDAY LESSON TWO
WEEKS AGO IS THAT CORRECT.
IT A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO I THINK
WAS WHEN THE FINAL BUT WHEN THE
FINAL LANGUAGE -- WAS SUBMITTED
UP STAIRS AND THEN SUBSEQUENT
WORK -- WAS -- WAS DONE TO IT
BUT REVISE IT WELL SURE IT WAS
EXACTLY ON FRIDAY BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT'S WHEN IT WENT TO
PRINCE A FEW DAYS BEFORE.
MR HOLDEN WAS IT FRIDAY LESSON
TWO WEEKS AGO THEY RECEIVE THE
LANGUAGE FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
WE RECEIVE THE LANGUAGE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HELLO ALL ALONG -- AND
ONCE WE RECEIVE THE OF WE BEGAN.
CONVERSATIONS AROUND ELEMENTS OF
THE BILL THAT WE THOUGHT NEEDED
TO BE -- SIMPLE IDEAS THAT WE
THOUGHT WERE APPROPRIATE TO
INTEGRATE INTO IT YES SORRY.
YEAH I'M I HAD A CHANCE -- TO TO
READ THE EDITORIALS OF THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHRONICLE.
THE LA TIMES OP ED ON THIS BILL
IS.
CALIFORNIA RACING TO PASS A
BADLY VETTED WHAT FAR BILL --
THAT -- THAT WERE BEING.
THAT THIS BILL [inaudible]
I'D.
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PASS THIS
WEEK.
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE ON
EDITORIAL IT TALKS ABOUT.
A QUOTE HERE THEY'RE CONCLUDING
STATEMENT IT'S MORE PORT TO GET
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR RIGHT THAN TO
GET A PASSED QUICKLY THE STATE
ASSEMBLY MUST RESIST THE
PRESSURE AND STOP GIVING THIS
BILL A FAST RUN TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK.
SO.
MY QUESTION BACK TO MS MODEST
SANTOS IS.
WHY THE RUSH -- TO PASSES BILL
IN LESS THAN TWO WEEKS.
THIS LEGISLATION IS THE WORK OF
CONSIDERABLE WORK BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
IT BUILDS ON SB NINE A ONE FROM
LAST YEAR IT REFLECTS THE WORK
OF THE STRIKE FORCE THAT -- THE
WHAT WHERE THE REPORT WAS
RELEASED A FEW THAT SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO IT REFLECTS THE WORK
OF THE SB NINE A ONE COMMISSION.
THAT HAS GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS HOW TO POP SAID A PUBLIC
HEARINGS ARE WORKING ON
EXTENSIVE -- INPUT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS IS.
WE THE THERE'S THERE'S CHALLENGE
TO TAKE ACTION TO STABILIZE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE LOOKING AT IT
THE CURRENT SITUATION WHERE THE
RATE PAID EXPOSURE ASSOCIATED
WITH.
A POTENTIAL DOWNGRADES WITH
POTENTIAL BANKRUPTCY WITH
GREATER INSTABILITY -- IS IS
GREAT AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
WORK A LOT OF PUBLIC DISCUSSION
MANY PUBLIC HEARINGS ABOUT
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL THAT HAS HAVE LED TO TO
TO THE LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU --
ACTION IS IS CRITICAL TO GET TO
A PLACE OF BOTH PROVIDING -- A
MECHANISM FOR RELIEF FOR VICTIMS --
PROVIDING IMPORTANT RATE PAYER
PROTECTIONS IN AVOIDING A HIGHER
BORROWING COSTS -- HIGHER COST
RECOVERY ASSOCIATED WITH CURRENT
LAW AND AND GETTING TO A PATH
WHERE WE CAN YOU KNOW GET THE
GET THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT NEED
TO OCCUR.
RELATIVE TO SAFETY
ACCOUNTABILITY INTO PLACE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND I APPRECIATE.
TO MS MONSANTO'S SWEET WE HAD A
CHANCE. TO TO AND MEET WITH YOU
IN THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF
YESTERDAY -- TO TAKEN.
A DEEPER DIVE IN INTO THE BILL I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF GOOD IN THIS
BILL AND AND I YOU KNOW FIRST OF
ALL I I I WANT -- TO RESPECT ALL
THE VICTIMS HERE AND IN THE
AUDIENCE -- AS WELL AS OUT
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE -- YOU KNOW
AND I I I REALIZE THAT -- THIS.
IS PRETTY HEAVY STUFF THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH HERE AND IT'S
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH HEAVY STUFF
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE.
I AM I AM CONCERNED THAT WERE
WERE -- RUSHING THIS THROUGH
WITH MANY MEMBERS NOT FULLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE'RE VOTING
ON HERE -- ONE OF MY CONCERNS IS --
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE EDITORIAL THAT -- THAT --
ACCORDING TO BE.
EDITORIAL THE WATCHFIRE DAMAGES
FUND CREATED BY A. B. TEN FIFTY
FOUR INCLUDES A CAP.
ON REIMBURSEMENTS FROM COMPANIES
THAT ARE FOUND HAVE ACTED
UNREASONABLY TO HAVE STARTED A
FIRE.
IS THAT ACCURATE MS MONSANTO'S.
I I BELIEVE THAT IS NOT FULLY
CAPTURING THE STRUCTURE THAT IS
INCLUDED IN THE MEASURE
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT FOR
EXAMPLE SO IT'S REFERRING I
BELIEVE TO THE DEDUCTIBLE
ELEMENT OF THE OF THE MEASURE
AND TAKING THAT PIECE IN
ISOLATION AND NOT LOOKING AT THE
WAY IN WHICH THAT.
DEDUCTIBLE GOES AWAY IF AN
ENTITY DOES NOT HAVE -- DOES NOT
HAVE A SAFETY CERTIFICATION AND
IF AN ENTITY -- IS WILLFULLY
ACTING IN A WAY THAT -- THAT IS
CAUSING THE THE BEHAVIOR UNDER
BOTH OF THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES THE
ENTITY WOULD HAVE TO RE
REIMBURSE THE FUN FOR A 100% OF
THE COST.
SO IF WE STEP BACK AND WE KIND
OF LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS THAT -- MISS BURKE
SPOKE TO AND RELATIVE TO TO HOW
THE THE BILL THE STRUCTURE.
FRONT AND SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
ANNUAL PLANS THOSE ANNUAL PLANTS
REQUIRE PROGRESS REPORTS THOSE
PROGRESS RICK BUT REPORTS ALSO
ACCOMPANIED BY FIELD EVALUATIONS --
SO ACTUAL BOOTS ON THE GROUND
VERIFYING THE UTILITIES ARE
DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO FULL ENFORCEMENT ACTION
INITIALLY WITHIN THE P. YOU SEE
SUBSEQUENTLY WITHIN THE
STANDALONE DEPARTMENT THAT IS
GOING TO BE SOLELY FOCUSED ON ON
THE THE YOU KNOW THE SAFETY OF
OUR ELECTRICITY.
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE --
THOSE THAT DOES CERTIFICATION
HAS TO BE IN PLACE IN ORDER FOR
A UTILITY TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
FUND.
THE UTILITIES ALSO ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO PRE FUND TEN AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS OF OF OF FUNDING
INTO THAT FUND TO MAKE IT
AVAILABLE FOR CLAIMS PAYING
RESOURCES IN THE CASE OF UTILITY
COSTS WILDFIRES.
THAT IF THAT FUND THAT TEN AND A
HALF BILLION COMES WITH A
DEDUCTIBLE.
THAT DEDUCTIBLE THOUGH VERY
SPACED ON REPAIR I'M SORRY ON
UTILITY BEHAVIOR IF THE
UTILITIES ACT PRUDENTLY THEN THE
FUND WOULD PAY THE CLAIMS THE
UTILITIES DON'T HAVE ADDITIONAL
CONTRIBUTIONS.
IF THE UTILITIES DON'T DO WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO BUT ACT
BUT BUT DO HAVE A VALID
CERTIFICATE ENACT WITHIN REASON.
THEY WOULD HAVE.
A DEDUCTIBLE THAT DEDUCTIBLE
WOULD BURY THEIR TOTAL EXPOSURE
ON THE THAT DEDUCTIBLE IS THIRTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
ANOTHER THIRTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS OF THE UTILITIES WOULD
HAVE TO FUND WITHOUT RECOVERY.
WITHOUT ANY COST RECOVERY FOR
RATEPAYERS THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR CLAIMS PAYING
RESOURCES AS WELL IF THE
UTILITIES HOWEVER DON'T HAVE A
VALID CERTIFICATE OR DELL OR ACT
WILLFULLY -- OR NEGLIGENT OR
WILFUL IN THEIR IN THEIR
NEGLIGENCE ACTION THEY WOULD
HAVE TO REIMBURSE THE PHONE FOR
A 100% OF THE COST SO I THINK.
THAT THAT PIECE IS AN IS IS AN
ELEMENT BUT IT'S THE THE THE
EDITORIAL IS MISSING THE OTHER
TWO COMPONENTS UNDER WHICH THAT
CAP ACTUALLY GOES AWAY AND IS
NOT AVAILABLE TO A UTILITY THAT
IS NOT ACTING RESPONSIBLY ALL
RIGHT AND AND AND SO -- I I
BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS WHAT YOU
INDICATED EXPLAIN NOW IT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING AND SO I IS IT
DIDN'T THAT THAT SENSES
CHRONICLE STATEMENT DIDN'T SOUND.
ACCURATE AND I I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT BUT YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT THAT
RATE PAYERS ARE PROTECTED --
YEAH I I I EGGS MY MET WITH TURN
YESTERDAY AND AND AND THEY TOLD
ME THAT.
THEY ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE THERE'S A
CAP AND A CERTAINTY IN TERMS OF
HOW MUCH RATE PAYERS.
WOULD PAY ARE AND AND THAT WOULD%
BE THE TEN POINT FIVE BILLION --
THAT THAT THAT -- WE WOULD BE
COMING FROM THE D. W. R. FEES
YES FROM A FROM -- DRAPER
PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS OF THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS -- IN IN THE
MEASURE SO THE MEASURE
AUTHORIZES THE PEW SEEK TO ADOPT
THE EXTENSION OF THE THE W.
ALREADY TRUCK WHICH IS CHARGING
FOLKS ARE PAYING TODAY.
IT WOULD BE CAPS TO TEN AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS THE
RATE PAYER EXPOSURE UNDER THE
MEASURE.
WHILE THE FUND IS IN EFFECT IN
THERE ARE MECHANISMS IN PLACE
WE'VE MODELED AND WE BELIEVE THE
FUND WILL REMAIN IN PLACE FOR
TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS AND THAT IS
WITHOUT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION.
ADDITIONAL CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE
UTILITIES MAY HAVE TO MAKE BASED
ON THEIR BEHAVIOR -- SO THAT'S
THE AND THE THE OTHER PIECES
THERE'S A RATE PAYER US SAVING
SO UNDER.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE REQUIRED
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT MISS BURKE SPOKE TO
RELATIVE TO THE FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
UTILITIES UNDER CURRENT LAW
WOULD BE ABLE OR AT A RATE OF
RETURN ON THAT SO THAT THAT CAN
RANGE YOU KNOW BETWEEN YOU KNOW.
101010% 12% OR SO THEY UTILITIES
ARE SEEKING TO INCREASE THOSE
LIMITS THIS WOULD TAKE THOSE
DOLLARS TO ZERO THAT'S TWO AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS OF REPAIR
SAVINGS UNDER THIS MEASURE
COMPARED TO CURRENT LAW OKAY.
BUT BUT I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
QUALIFIER THAT YOU PUT INTO --
AND IN IN YOUR SEAT YEAH I WANT
TO RESPECT ALL OF THE MEMBERS
AND THEIR TIME FOR QUESTIONING
BUT I HAVE THREE OTHER MEMBERS
THAT ARE WAITING TO YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS CHAMP.
SO -- YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
QUALIFIER THAT YOU YOU INDICATED
IS THAT THE IS THAT THE CAP IN
THE CERTAINTY WOULD BE APPLY
WHILE THE FUND IS IN EFFECT IS
THAT CORRECT.
WHILE WHILE THE FUND HAS CLAIMS
BEING RESOURCES THE TEN AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS IS THE IS
THE AMOUNT AND WE BELIEVE THE
FUNDS WILL BE.
IN EFFECT FOR AT LEAST TEN TO
FIFTEEN YEARS COULD BE LONGER
ALL RIGHT BUT THE AT THE YOUR
YOUR PROJECTION IS IS THAT THIS
FUND WOULD BE.
A FORTY BILLION DOLLAR FUND --
THAT THAT -- IS PROJECTED TO BE
EFFECTIVE FOR TEN DO UP TO
FIFTEEN YEARS TO FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN CLAIMS PAYING
RESOURCES THAT WOULD PROVIDE --
THE PROVIDE -- COUPLE COVERED
BETWEEN AT LEAST TEN TO FIFTEEN
YEARS.
IT COULD BE LARGER SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU TELL THESE ARE
BAR HAVING TO PAY ADDITIONAL
DEDUCTIBLES.
THAT WOULD BE MORE MONEY INTO
THE FUND LONGER TIME PERIOD FOR
CLAIMS FAMILIES ALL RIGHT BUT WE
WE WE JUST HEARD.
TO THE MATH THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE.
A TESTIFIED THAT TEN OF THE LAST.
NO THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE A WILD
FIRES IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY HAVE
BEEN IN THE LAST. FOR YEARS HAVE
LIFE SINCE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND AND IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THERE IS THE
FIGURE THAT THE DAMAGES JUST
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS ESTIMATED TO BE
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS.
AND IT'S SO SO IT IT IT IT SEEMS
CLEAR -- JUST FROM THE HISTORY
THAT.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HERE AND NOW
IT'S ONLY GONNA GET WORSE WE
ALREADY SUFFERED TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE.
I DON'T FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THIS
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS IS GOING
TO LAST AS LONG AS YOU'RE YOU'RE
REPRESENTING.
IN THE MEANTIME WE ARE WEAKENING
THE PRUDENT MANAGEMENT STANDARD
THAT WILL ALLOW.
YOU KNOW THE COST TO BE PASSED
ON TO RATE PAYERS AT AT AT A
LOWER STANDARD [inaudible]
MY CONCERN.
IS THAT THIS IS.
READING IT'S OPENING THE WINDOW
FOR RATE PAYERS DIFFERENT
FURTHER BE SETTLED BY -- THE
EVER INCREASING WATER PARK US
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MISTER
MURATSUCHI -- QUIRK.
YES EGGMAN AND THEN WAS REYES
SAID RESPOND TO SOME OF MISTER
MAYOR SU CHI'S CONCERN.
IF WE WERE DOING THINGS THE SAME
WAY WE'VE DONE THEM FOR THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS THAT FUND WOULD
NOT LAST VERY LONG THE TWENTY
ONE BILLION.
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS
SOMETHING QUITE DIFFERENT WE ARE
TURNING OFF THE POWER TO THE
LINES ON A REGULAR BASIS.
ANY TIME THERE CONDITIONS THAT
WE KNOW WILL CAUSE A WILDFIRE.
OF THE TYPE THAT TO CURD -- THE
CAMPFIRE IT CETERA WE OF HIGH
WINDS LOW HUMIDITY HIGH
TEMPERATURES THE LINES ARE JUST
GETTING TURNED OFF.
MISTER GALLAGHER WHO HAS SEEN
MOST OF THESE CAN TELL YOU HOW
DISRUPTIVE THAT IS.
THE OTHER THING IS THEY'RE
ASKING FOR FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TO UPGRADE THE SYSTEM.
AND THAT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS --
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE BEST WAY
TO SPEND IT IS BUT FOR EXAMPLE --
THEY'RE LOOKING AT IF A WIRE
BREAKS THAT THEY THEN.
TURN OFF THE THE POWER TO THAT
WIRE INTERMITTENT THERE.
THERE ARE DOZENS OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT COULD BE DONE I
CAN'T TELL YOU WHICH ONES.
BUT THIS YOU'RE RIGHT IF WE DID
THINGS THE WAY WE'VE DONE THEM
FOR THE LAST HUNDRED YEARS THIS
FUND WOULD NOT LAST.
THE PEOPLE WHO LOOKED AT THIS
LOOKED AT IT TO DETERMINE WHAT
WAS NEEDED IF WE WENT WITH THE
NEW PROCEDURES.
I WILL SAY THAT.
THE OTHER THING THEY'VE DONE IS
WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT ADDISON
IN PARTICULAR -- BUT TO SOME
EXTENT SEMPRA.
FROM GOING INTO JUNK BOND STATUS
ARE ONCE THAT HAPPENS THERE'S A
SUBSTANTIAL RISK OF THEM GOING
INTO THE SAME BANKRUPTCY AT
WHICH POINT.
THE FED COURT TAKES OVER AND WE
HAVE VERY LITTLE -- LEVERAGE ONE
OF THE POINTS OF THIS BILL IS TO
GET P. GENIE OUT OF BANKRUPTCY
QUICKLY THEY CAN ONLY AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THIS FUND.
IF THEY CAN GET OUT QUICKLY AND
PART OF THAT IS SETTLING THEIR
CURRENT -- CLAIMS -- THE OTHER
THING SO THAT I THINK IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS I'LL
ALSO SAY THAT I DOUBT THAT
ANYONE AT THE CHRONICLE A REALLY
READ THE HUNDRED PAGES AND I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE -- LAST YEAR
I PUT OUT A BILL PRIOR TO NINE
NO.
ONE AND IT SAID QUIRK IS DOING A
BAILOUT WELL IF YOU READ MY BILL
IT SAID YES THE CUSTOMERS WILL.
PAY OFF.
OF THE THE CLAIMANTS BUT ALL OF
THAT MONEY WOULD THEN BE
REIMBURSED BY THE UNDERSTOOD
UTILITY.
NONE THE LESS EVEN THOUGH THAT
WAS A 100% REIMBURSEMENT TO THE
CUSTOMERS WHO WAS CALLED TO BAIL
OUT -- I JUST SHRUGGED IT OFF
BECAUSE PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT
NAOMI BUT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED --
FINALLY -- THERE'S ONE OTHER
ISSUE YOU BROUGHT UP AND I'M
TRYING TO REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS
IT WAS WITH ME A SECOND AGO.
THE MANAGEMENT AND WELL ON THE
MANAGEMENT STANDARD SO -- THE I
KNOW WHAT IT IS SO WHAT DID WE
DO ASK BEING CONSULTED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
THE FIRST THING IS THE NOT YOU
RECALL BECAUSE YOU WERE HERE THE
NINE NO WIND COMMISSION
SUGGESTED THAT WE GET RID OF
INVERSE CONDEMNATION -- I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT THE SPEAKER OF
THE AUTHORS TOLD -- THE GOVERNOR
THAT WAS A NO GO -- THERE ARE
OTHER -- EXAMPLES OF THINGS THAT
WERE IN THERE THE COMMISSION
ALSO SAID THE NINE A ONE
COMMISSION SAID THAT THERE
SHOULD BE THE PURE. FOR BURKE
STANDARD WHAT IN FACT WE'VE DONE
IS YES SO THE CURRENT STANDARD
IS GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT.
THE FIRST STANDARD IS INNOCENT
TILL PROVEN GUILTY.
IF YOU'VE AND BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT IS IN FACT IN THIS BILL
WHICH IN THIS BILL IS.
UP FOR THERE TO BE IN A
PRESUMPTION THAT YOU ARE A GOOD
PLAYER YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN
ACCEPTED WILDFIRE -- PLAN AND
YOU HAVE TO BEEN DOING THE WORK.
AND IF SOMEONE CAN SHOW THAT IN
FACT YOU HAVEN'T -- DONE THE
THINGS YOU SAID YOU WERE GOING
TO DO THEN THE PRESUMPTION GOES
BACK TO GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN
INNOCENT SO IT'S NOT AT ALL.
WHAT WAS SUGGESTED IN THE NINE A
ONE COMMISSION OR FRANKLY WITH
THE GOVERNOR WANTED?
THE FINAL I'D LIKE TO BRING UP
ONE SEPARATE ISSUE.
SO THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
I'M ALSO GETTING THIS FROM A
COUPLE OF MY CONSTITUENTS HAVE
SAID THAT.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO TAKE OVER
THE PGA ANY LINES.
NOW AS I READ THE BILL AS A
LABOR PROTECTION ITEM.
IT SAYS ANY TAKEOVER BY A NOTHER --
ENTITY OF SAY P. JEANNIE LINES
OR FOR THAT MATTER ADD THIS IN
SEPARATE CETERA.
ANY TAKEOVER OF THAT TYPE MUST
GO THROUGH THE P. YOU SEE
PROCESS.
THAT IS A WAY OF PROTECTING RATE
PAYERS AND A WAY OF PROTECTING
LABOR SO THAT PEOPLE KEEP THEIR
SENIORITY -- THEY'LL STILL GET
THEIR VACATION PAY THEY WON'T
HAVE THEIR PAY -- KEEP THEIR
VACATION TIME THEY WON'T HAVE
THEIR PAY REDUCED IT CETERA
THOSE ARE LABOR NOW THAT DOES
TAKE LONGER.
THAN THE ALTERNATIVE WHICH IS TO
DO EMINENT DOMAIN.
IT IS POSSIBLE FOR AN ENTITY ACT
ACT COUNTY OR CITY. TO DO
EMINENT DOMAIN AND TAKE OVER
THOSE WIRES -- THAT'S WHAT'S
TRYING TO BE PREVENTED BY THIS
PALE.
BY GOING THROUGH THE P. YOU SEEK.
PROCESS WE PROTECT RATE PAYERS
WE PROTECT FURTHER OF POSSIBLE
VICTIMS AND WE PROTECT LABOR.
SO -- IF ANYONE WANTS TO RESPOND
TO THAT CONCERN AND I KNOW --
BUT WE HEARD FROM -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU HIS CONCERNS ABOUT
IT IF ONE OF THE EXPERTS WOULD
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE PROCESS.
BY WHICH SAN FRANCISCO OR SOME
OTHER ENTITY COULD TAKE OVER
PART OF THAT.
I OWE YOU SYSTEM I'D BE GLAD TO
HEAR THAT.
THE LABOR PROVISIONS.
A LIST OF WHAT WE CAN.
DO YOU CAN OR WE CAN HAVE.
A BUSINESS WHERE CHAIR IN THE
PROCESS I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL.
A MOTION AND A SECOND -- HAVING
BEEN ON THE RECEIVING END OF A
VERY GRACIOUS CHAIR TO CUT MY
OWN REMARKS SHORT IN TIMES PAST.
I'M JUST GOING TO SUGGEST THAT
WE DO HAVE WERE UP AGAINST SOME
DEGREE OF TIME NOT THAT I WANT
TO RUSH IT.
I'M NOT I I'M GONNA GIVE
EVERYBODY AN OPPORTUNITY TO THE
QUESTION WHO WITH WHOMEVER THEY
THEY WANT.
TO WE HAVE A SERIES OF THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN RECOGNIZED SO WE'RE
GONNA GO WITH MS MS EGGMAN AND
THEN MS REYES.
THANK YOU AND I AND MR PART OF
MY QUESTION HAD TO DO WITH THAT
LAST PART OF MISTER QUIRK SO I
THOUGHT I THOUGHT FOR TIME. FOR
TIME ISSUES WE COULD DO THIS --
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION -- AND AS WE SAY.
IN IN MY OFFICE WE IN CALIFORNIA
VERY GLAD THAT I'M A SCIENTIST
IS ON OUR SIDE -- IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- SO I THINK
EVERYBODY FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THIS.
AND I'M NOT A PROSECUTOR
SCIENTIST LIKE MR QUIRK I'M JUST
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRYING TO
REPRESENT MY COMMUNITY -- SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I WANT TO ASK
ABOUT IS VERY ISSUE THAT MR
QUIRK REYES AT THE END ABOUT THE
MUNY SNOW AND I UNDERSTAND.
NO MISTER.
WHAT'S GOT UP AND TALKED ABOUT
WE DON'T WANT TO HEDGE FUND
BUYING OFF PARTS AND AND JUST.
NO NOBODY WANTS THAT RIGHT
NOBODY WANTS THAT AND I BUT I AM
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND UNDERSTAND THAT WE
NEED TO STABILIZE EVERYTHING --
BUT THEY'RE ALL I MEAN I THINK
WE ALSO NEED.
TO PROVIDE SPACE IF THERE ARE.
VIABLE OTHER PROJECTS OUT THERE
IN MY DISTRICT SINCE IT FOR
CLOSE TO MY DISTRICT SINCE.
THE BEGINNING OF THE OF TWO
THOUSANDS SOUTH
TELECOMMUNICATION DISTRICT HAS
BEEN TRYING TO TAKE OVER PART OF
THE P. JEAN AREA AND HAS BEEN A
LONG AN ONGOING FIGHT AND THEY
ARE UNION SHOP.
THEY ARE AND I B. W. SHOT.
AND SO THEIR ISSUES ARE ARE NOT
AROUND THE EMPLOYEES BUT ITS
AROUND THE EXTRA WHO THEN THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO THERE
ALREADY IN IN MY DOMAIN AND THEN
TO THE PC.
SO I THINK THOSE ARE THE REAL
ISSUES.
I CAN TELL YOU I WAS AT A AND
ALSO SPEAK TO THE ISSUES UP AS
SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS LIKE
MISTER PATTERSON AGRICULTURAL.
A DISTRICT IN THE VALLEY.
RIGHT SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
EXTENDING THAT THAT FEE IT IS
HIGHER FOR PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THE VALLEY AREAS AND AS AS SOME
OF MY MY FRIENDS WILL SAY WE DUG
A CULTURE WE SERVE AS A FIRE.
A BUFFER RIGHT BIG WILD FIRES
ARE NOT GONNA OCCUR WHERE THERE
IS MANAGE AGRICULTURE GOING ON
USE MORE POWER IN PROCESSING --
HAVE LESS CHANCES OF WILDFIRES
BUT OUR CLUSTER HIGHER.
SO THAT'S I MEAN JUST ON ITS
FACE VALUE THAT IS IN IN EQUITY
THAT I THINK NEEDS PROPPED ON IN
THIS BILL.
BUT A TENSION GOING FORWARD.
AND THEN -- I WAS AT THE END
BECAUSE WE HAVE.
THE POWER LINES COMING OUT OF
THIS YEAR IS INTO THE BAY AREA
IN OTHER PLACES.
GOING OVER PART OF THE VITAMIN
TAKE AREA THERE ARE POWER LINES
SO EVERYONE'S GETTING NOTICES
NOW THAT THEIR POWER WE MIGHT BE
POWERED OFF.
SO THE SAME TIME YOU'RE TELLING
FOLKS NEEDS SALT SORRY SOUTH
SOMEONE CAN YOUR GEISHA DISTRICT
YOU CAN'T BECAUSE WE HAVE TO THE
P. JEANNIE DO ITP. GENIUS AND
WE'RE GONNA POWER OFF -- AND I
KNOW PEOPLE HAVE DIED AND I HAVE
RELATIVES IN THE PARADISE AREA I
HAVE BEEN.
YOU KNOW I HAVE BEEN TO THE
WILDFIRES I AM A LONGTIME LOVER
THIS YEAR'S.
BUT I HAD A GENTLEMAN IN MANTECA.
MORNING ME TO GUARANTEE HIM.
THE P. GINNY WAS GOING TO PAY
FOR HIS MEAT IN HIS FREEZER IF
THEY HAD A TURN OFF THE POWER
FOR TWO DAYS.
RIGHT SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THIS BIG GRID STABILIZATION YOU
HAVE PEOPLE AS THEY SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEMSELVES.
RIGHT SO WE THAT'S WHY WE NEED
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET
IT RIGHT AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
AND SO ONE OF THE THING I WANT
TO ASK DO YOU SPEAK ABOUT THE
CERTIFICATION IT'S ALSO ABOUT.
A YOU CAN'T BE CERTIFIED IF YOU
HAVE DONE MASSIVE PAYOUTS FOR
YOUR EXECUTIVES COULD YOU ALSO
SPEAK TO THAT AND THEN.
IS IT WILL THERE BE SOME
ADJUSTMENT GOING FORWARD ON THAT --
OTHER ENTITIES WANTING TO TAKE
OVER A PIECE IF IT MAKES SENSE.
FOR THE COMMUNITY AND FOR
EVERYBODY SURROUNDING IT AND
THEN AND AGAIN ABOUT THAT.
THAT FEED THAT IS GOING TO BE
LARGER IN MY DISTRICT AND IT'S
GOING TO BE IN MISTER QUIRK OR
MISTER MERCY JUST DISTRICT. FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO USE MORE
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S HOTTER AND WE
USED.
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND.
I THINK WE MIGHT ALL WANT TO BUT
BUT MAYBE WE CAN JUST HAVE --
THE SMALLER SALAS KIND OF
CAPTURE OKAY SOME OF THE BIG
BOYS WILL FOLLOW PLEASE.
IF I MAY ON THE ON THE ISSUE OF
THE YOU KNOW P. JEANNIE
DISPOSITION OF P. JEANNIE.
PROPERTIES WHAT IS THE FUTURE P.
JEANNIE LOOK LIKE IT CETERA YOU
KNOW ALL THE ALL THE QUESTIONS
OF REORGANIZATION OF P. JEANNIE --
THE MATTERS OF DISPOSITION OF
PROPERTY ALL OF THOSE ELEMENTS
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT.
SO -- ALL THE QUESTIONS AROUND
WHAT IS THE THE THE PLAN OF
REORGANIZATION THAT WILL BE
APPROVED BY -- BY THE COURT IS
IN AND ALL OF THE QUESTIONS
RELATIVE TO THE PROPERTY GIVEN
THE FACT THAT P. GENIE IS THE
ENTITY IN BANKRUPTCY ALL THOSE
ISSUES.
ARE PART OF THE SCOPE OF WHAT
THE BANKRUPTCY COURT WILL BE
WORKING THROUGH WHAT THE MET ONE
OF THE PIECES OF THE MEASURE
SAYS ON THAT POINT OF THE
EQUATION IS IT SAYS.
THAT BANKRUPTCY THE TERMS OF THE
BANKRUPTCY IT HAS TO BE THERE
HAS TO BE -- REPAIR NEUTRAL IT
HAS TO PAY THE VICTIMS OF THE
TERM BY THE COURT IN FULL.
ON THE TIME OF SPECIFIED BY THE
COURT IT HAS TO PROVIDE FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
REQUIREMENTS AND RIVER INCLUDING
OUR PS AND OTHER ELEMENTS.
AND THE THE PC HAS -- TO HAS TO
CERTIFY THAT THE THE IT THAT THE
PC HAS TO CERTIFY.
THAT THE PLAN OF REORGANIZATION
CONSIDERS THE CONTRIBUTION FROM
RATEPAYERS INAPPROPRIATE USHER
INCLUDE POTENTIAL VALUE SHARING
SO THE THE ACTUAL DETAILED P.
JEANNIE PROPERTY REORGANIZATION
QUESTIONS AT CENTER OF THOSE ARE
MATTERS BEFORE THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT.
IN TERMS OF THE ELEMENTS IN THE
PROTECTION OF THE IN THE BILL AS
YOU MENTIONED.
THE MANY OF THESE WORKER
PROTECTIONS WERE IN PLACE IN SB
NINE OH ONE AND ARE PART OF ARE
PART OF CURRENT LAW TO GET
EXTENDED FOR ANOTHER YEAR.
THIS IS THE MUNICIPAL STATION
PROCESS -- YOU KNOW THAT THE
STATUTE RELATIVE TO HELP IN THIS
POSITION WE WOULD MOVE FORWARD
REMAINS IN PLACE. FOR FOR
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS WHAT THIS
SAYS IT IN THE INTO THE CHANGES
ARE INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE CRITICAL PROTECTIONS
TO THE WORKERS.
THAT -- AND THAT IS IMPORTANT
NOT ONLY FOR THE WORKERS
THEMSELVES FOR THEIR BENEFITS
FOR THE STABILITY ETCETERA BUT
IT'S ALSO.
THIS IS NOT AN AREA WHERE WE
HAVE A SURPLUS OF OF QUALIFIED
WORKERS SO FOR THE SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS -- FOR THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT IS SOUGHT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE -- THAT WE HAVE CONTINUITY
IN THE WORK FORCE OUT SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE THE SAFETY INVESTMENTS
THE TRANSFORMATION THE CONTINUED
A RELIABLE SERVICE WHICH IS
ACTUALLY A REALLY IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF INSURING THAT THE THE
PS PS THE CURRENT SHOT OFF THAT
ARE BEING DONE.
ARE USED TO SPARE LEAST POSSIBLE
THAT ELECTRICITY IS RIPPED
RESTORED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE --
AND THAT WE GET TO A PLACE WHERE
WE DON'T HAVE THE INTERRUPTIONS
THAT ARE THAT ARE CURRENTLY --
THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING
CONSIDERED SO YOU KNOW THE PART
OF THE THE THE IT GETTING IT
GETTING GOING ON THESE
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
GETTING THE GREAT HARDENING
GETTING THE OTHER ELEMENTS IN
PLACE THAT MAKES IT POSSIBLE --
FOR GETS PGA ANY CLOSER TO WORST
INDIO GAS AND ELECTRIC IS WHERE
WHEN THEY LOOK AT CONDITIONS ANY
ANY SHOW ANY INTERRUPTIONS ARE
SHORTER.
MORE LOCALIZED THE POWER --
RESTORATION HAPPENS FASTER --
THE SAFETY INVESTMENTS THE NEW
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE.
THAT IS HAPPENING YOU KNOW WHERE
WHERE THE SERVICE INTERRUPTION
THAT FOLKS ARE ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING IN P. JEANNIE
SERVICE TERRITORY IN EDISON
TERRITORY HAPPENS IS A CELL THE
MOST POSSIBLE SO.
IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL -- YOU
KNOW AND THE OVERALL WORKER
PROTECTIONS WE WE THINK THEY'RE
VERY CRITICAL THE CHANGES ARE
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT.
THE PC HAS OVERSIGHT WHEN THERE
ARE NOT AGREEMENTS REACHED OR
WHEN THERE IS NOT OR WHEN THE
BENEFITS THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED
UNDER A SUCCESSOR TO PGA ANY.
IN A SERVICE TERRITORY WOULD
HAVE BENEFITS THAT ARE INFERIOR
TO THOSE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PROVIDED SO IF THERE'S AN
AGREEMENT OR IF THERE ARE -- IF
THERE ARE BENEFITS THAT ARE AT
THE SAME LEVEL OR HIGHER THAN
THESE PROVISIONS -- DON'T DON'T --
YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
BASICALLY THERE IS A BUILT IN
MECHANISM FOR FOLKS TO NOT HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE OVERSIGHT
PROCESS IT IT'S PROVIDING THE
WORKER PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY.
TO DO THAT WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH -- WITH THE
VARIOUS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
HAVE RAISED ISSUES AND IF THERE
OFFER SEEN CIRCUMSTANCE IF
THEY'RE UNFORESEEN CHALLENGES.
WE YOU KNOW WE WILL -- WE WILL
BRING THIS TO THE ATTENTION BUT
OUR SENSES IT'S REALLY CRITICAL
TO HAVE THESE WORKER PROTECTIONS
AND WE THINK THESE CHANGES ARE
JUSTIFIED IN APPROACH.
YEAH WHAT.
EVERYBODY AGREES THAT THE
WORKERS SHOULD BE PROTECTED AND
I THINK IT'S ABOUT BOB WELL
KNOWN ISSUE THAT THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH WORKERS TO GO AROUND
RIGHT NOW SO WE NEED TO PROTECT
THE ONES WE HAVE.
THE WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S
NOT.
NOT JUST MAKING SURE.
P. JEANNIE GETS A CONTINUE
PRACTICING BAD BEHAVIOR AND THAT
WE MAKE THINGS EASIER FOR THEM
RATHER THAN HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
IF I MAY ON THE QUESTION OF
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION THIS IS
ONE OF THE THIS IS ONE OF THE
AREAS WHERE THE AMENDMENTS --
HAVE SUBSTANTIALLY STRENGTHENED
THE BILL INCLUDED MUCH MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND AND AND SKIN IN THE GAME NOT
ONLY FOR THE CORPORATIONS WOULD
FOR EXECUTIVE SO THERE ARE
STRONG PROVISIONS IN THE MEASURE
WHERE THE PC WILL HAVE TO REVIEW
THE PLANS FOR INCENTIVES THAT
ARE.
THAT THE THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES HAVE AND THERE'S
LANGUAGE AROUND YOU KNOW LOOKING
AT NO -- NO INCENTIVES BEING.
FOLKS NOT BEING ELIGIBLE FOR
INCENTIVES OR BONUSES WHEN THE
UTILITY BECAUSE THE WALL FAR THE
LEADS IN LATIN TO THE DEATH
THEY'RE BROUGHT IT BROADER
STANDARDS THAT.
THAT TIED TO JUST BROADLY
LINKING.
COMPENSATION INCENTIVE BONUSES
TO SAFETY.
ANY CRITERIA THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED BUT KEY ONES WOULD BE
DETAILED WITH THE POSSIBILITY
BUT NO 1100% INCENTIVE NOT BEING
PROVIDED WHEN.
WHEN AN ENTITY IS NOT MEETING
ITS SAFETY OBLIGATIONS AND OR
WHEN IT CAUSES A WILDFIRE THAT
RESULTS AND -- AND IN ONE OR
MORE FATALITIES AND I THINK I
DID SIGNAL WHICH MEANT WHEN I
SAID THAT PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS ARE PAYING
HIGHER RATES AND I I THINK I SAW
THAT KNOWLEDGE MAN ON THAT AND
HAVE LOWER.
WILDFIRES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ABOUT FOUR AM I
RECOGNIZE MEMORIES ARE THERE
OTHER MEMBERS THAT WISH TO BE.
RECOGNIZED.
MR TANG ANY OTHERS.
AT AND WE'LL GO WITH THESE THREE
AND BRING IT TO A CONCLUSION.
FAST PACKED WITH GREAT MEMORIES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
FIRST I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE.
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAIR HOLDEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AND TO THE
GOVERNOR THE ADMINISTRATION --
THIS HAS BEEN -- QUITE AN ORDEAL
PUTTING ALL OF THIS TOGETHER.
I I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT IS
A MEMBER OF LAST YEARS SB.
NINE OH ONE FRIENDS COMMITTEE I
RECOGNIZE.
I UNDERSTAND THE SERIOUS NATURE
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
WE'RE TRYING TO STABILIZE
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE BENEFIT OF
CALIFORNIA NOT FOR THE BENEFIT
OF CORPORATIONS ARE INVESTORS
BUT FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
VICTIMS IN THE RATE PAYERS AND
THE WORKERS.
AND FOR CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE.
I I REALLY I I I HAVE SPOKEN
WITH EACH OF YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT YOU
HAVE.
GIVEN TO TO TO US AS MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND TWO OTHER
COLLEAGUES. TO TO TAKE TIME TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS OF THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE EACH OF YOU
INDIVIDUALLY THE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD LOTS OF
QUESTIONS.
THAT'S WHY.
EVEN TO NOW I STILL STRUGGLE
WITH.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR AS I READ IT.
AND I HAVE READ IT.
AND I SIT WITH MEMBERS WHO HAVE
READ IT NOT ONLY WHEN IT WAS
FIRST PRESENTED TO US BUT EVEN
AFTER THE AMENDMENTS.
IT TAKES TIME TO READ THROUGH IT
BUT WE HAVE READ IT BECAUSE THIS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US.
MANY HAVE SAID AND I AGREE THE
BILL IS FAR FROM PERFECT.
IN THE PROCESS THAT WAS TAKEN TO
BRING IT BEFORE US HAS ALSO BEEN
LESS THAN PERFECT.
I'M CONCERNED THAT THE BILL.
PROPOSES A SHIFTING OF THE
BURDEN. FOR TALKING ABOUT THE
CONDUCT OF THE UTILITIES.
CHANGING IT FROM THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR ELECTRICAL
[inaudible]
OPERATIONS.
WHEN THEY HAVE THEIR CERTIFICATE?
I KNOW THAT THAT I SPEAK FOR SO
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES.
THERE WERE HOPEFUL THAT THE
CERTIFICATION WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE THAT THAT
CERTIFICATION WILL REALLY
SIGNIFIED THAT THESE ARE GOOD
PLAYERS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE IS
NO GUARANTEE.
AND MY GREATEST CONCERN.
IS HOLDING THE TELE TO USE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR.
I I'M REALLY CONCERNED THAT
WE'RE BEING ASKED TO ASSESS THE
BEST COURSE OF ACTION TO ADDRESS
THIS NEW REALITY OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES [inaudible]
GET IT. FOR IT BEING ASKED TO
TAKE A LEAP OF FAITH.
ON A BILL.
WE'VE SEEN IN PRINT.
FOR A FEW WEEKS.
WITH LIMITED OPPORTUNITY. FOR
THOUGHTFUL AMENDMENTS.
AND MORE ROBUST [inaudible]
CONVERSATION.
I THINK THAT AS A LEGISLATURE WE
NEED TO ASK OURSELVES.
ARE WE CREATING A MORAL HAZARD.
HOW WE CREATED A SITUATION WE
DEPEND SO MUCH ON A CORPORATION?
THAT WE FEEL WE MUST REGARDLESS
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
ENSURE THEIR SUCCESS.
THESE ARE THE ISSUES THAT I
GRAPPLE WITH THE WORLD.
ALSO UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACT
OUR ACTIONS WILL HAVE ON
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE AIR
POLLUTION.
THE PROTECTION OF RATE PAYERS A
PROTECTION OF VICTIMS THE
PROTECTION OF OUR WORKERS.
AND THE RICH IN THE END THE
RELIABILITY OF OUR ELECTRIC GRID.
HI I I EXPRESSED MY CONCERN WITH
WITH WITH EACH OF YOU AND I I
AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
TIME THAT YOU'VE PUT INTO THIS.
BECAUSE IT IS CLEAR THAT YOU'VE
PUT IN SO MUCH TIME AND YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS YOU'RE
PRESENTING TO US.
BUT BUT I I REMAIN TORN ON THIS
BILL.
AND I DO QUESTION WHETHER WHAT
WE'RE PRESENTED WITH THE NOW
[inaudible]
IN.
THE AS IT IN THE CURRENT DRAFT
THAT WE HAVE.
WITH THIS LIMITED TIME THAT
WE'VE HAD TO DELIBERATE.
WHETHER THIS IS THE BEST THAT WE
CAN DO [inaudible]
PROTECT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARE AYE
FIRST I JUST WANT TO THANK.
THE THREE AUTHORS THE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR WORKING.
IT GREEN OF EXTREMELY HARD SINCE
SINCE JANUARY ON PUTTING THIS
PACKAGE TOGETHER AS I'VE
MENTIONED TO DIFFERENT PEOPLE
INDIVIDUALLY I THINK THERE'S A
LOT TO LIKE.
ABOUT THIS PACKAGE.
IT'S VERY IT'S VERY THOUGHTFUL
IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT THE
SHAREHOLDER FUNDS.
REALLY COME FIRST OVER RATE
PAYER FUNDS I THINK THAT'S VERY
WELL DELINEATED -- VERY HAPPY
THE SEEDS STICK SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE OVERSIGHT OVER VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND REALLY FLUSHING
OUT THAT PROCESS THAT WAS IN SB
NINE OH ONE THERE.
REALLY DICTATES ON THAT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT SUPPOSED
TO CURRENT NO THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS WHEN WE TOOK THAT THE
LAST YEAR -- IN HOW THIS PROCESS
TO PLAY OUT TO THINK THIS IS THE
NEXT ITERATION OF THAT IT'S IT'S
VERY GOOD.
TO SEE THAT IN THE END IT NAY
LAST THAT THINK THE THE BILL HAS
DONE -- YOU KNOW FAIRLY
IMPRESSIVE JOB THAT BALANCING A
VERY BROAD ARRAY OF STAKEHOLDERS
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN SITTING ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
FOR MOST OF MY TIME MY PIERCING
WHEN YOU SEE.
ON THE ELECTRICAL WORKERS WITH
IOUS WITH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES.
WITH TURNED WITH.
THE ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND
CONSUMER TERRY'S IT'S A FAIRLY --
IMPRESSIVE GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS
TO BE ABLE TO BRING TOGETHER
IT'S VERY RARE. TO SEE THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY MY PROBLEM IS THE
PROBLEM THAT -- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM HE WOULD ARTICULATED
REGARDING THE INVOLUNTARY
INVOLUNTARY CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP
OF ASSETS FROM COULD ELECTRICAL
COMPANY TO OUR PUBLIC ENTITY AND
SO I THINK.
THAT THAT'S CREATED A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
CONSTERNATION IN OPPOSITION IN
MY OWN CITY -- THAT'S MATED --
CHALLENGING FOR FOR ME TO
SUPPORT IT I KNOW OUR SENATOR --
WAS NOT ABLE TO SAY.
WE WE HOPE THAT IN THE FUTURE
THAT THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE CAN
BE ADDRESSED.
BUT AT THIS POINT I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATION AS IT'S
WRITTEN BECAUSE AT THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AND MEMBER GARCIA AND I BELIEVE
THAT IS IT ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED
[inaudible]
IF NOT [inaudible]
UP.
FLOOR IS YOURS AND THEN WILL
LOVE ASK FOR THE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU -- WHEN THIS WHEN THIS
BILL?
THERE WAS THROUGH AN ARTICLE OR
DRUGS ALLOW INTEREST CAME BEFORE
US A FEW WEEKS AGO TWO TWO DAY
THERE HAVE DEFINITELY BEEN
AMENDMENTS AND TAKING A NUMBER
OF US HAVE.
POINTED OUT DIFFERENT WEAKNESSES
WITHIN THE BILL AND AND I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
HAS BEEN MEANT.
AND AMENDMENTS THERE BUT I THINK
MY CONCERN IS THE BIGGER PICTURE
ABOUT A PICTURE.
OF WHETHER OR NOT WE LOOK THAT
AND REALLY TOOK SERIOUSLY EIGHT
THE IDEA OF A DIFFERENT MODEL --
AND OUR ELECTRICITY SECTOR OUT
THERE AND WHETHER WE'VE GIVEN
THAT IN NO TIME AND I DON'T FEEL
THAT WE HAVE I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT WAS EVEN CONSIDERED WHEN
THE DISCUSSIONS -- STARTED WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
AUTHORS OUT THERE IN A DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS.
IN DISCUSSIONS WHETHER IT'S TO
DO MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN TO
SCHOOL TALKING ABOUT. SEVENTY
THE FERRY TO HAVE A PUBLIC
ENTITY WHETHER IT'S IN STOCK
THEN WITH DIFFERENT FOLKS OUT
THERE HAVE BROUGHT IT UP BUT IN
GENERAL MY DISCUSSION IS NOT
JUST ABOUT THIS PUBLIC ENTITIES
BUT JUST.
HAS THE EXPERIMENT WE BEEN DOING
FIT.
THE REALITY OF CALIFORNIA NOT
JUST WITH CLIMATE CHANGE WITH
WILDFIRES WITH ALL THE OTHER
POLICIES WE HAVE THEM OF
RENEWABLES AND EVERYTHING ELSE
ALONG THE WAY.
IT'S A CRISIS ALLOWS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND I DON'T FEEL
THAT WE'VE TAKEN ADVANTAGEOF
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND WE ARE
WHERE WE HAD TO DO AND AND OUR
WINDOW HAS CLOSED.
GIVEN HERE SEVEN YEARS AND I
HAVE BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE ALL
SEVEN YEARS.
AND IT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE THAT
WHAT WE SAY YES WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK AND REVISIT THAT WE DON'T --
AND THAT'S WHERE MY CONCERN
COMES TO DAY -- WITH WITH WHERE
WE'RE AT TODAY.
INSIDE OUT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND YOU KNOW IF A DIMINISH YOU
SAID THE GOVERNOR IS GOING TO BE
JUST AS VALID AS HE WAS WITH
THIS BILL WITH A BIGGER
DISCUSSION.
INTO THE PHALLUS AS FAR AS THE
TIME LANDING AT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND ESPECIALLY IF US
MUSCLE NOT JUST A STRIKE FIRST
BUT TO DO OTHER.
THINGS -- BECAUSE I HAVEN'T I'VE
I HAVEN'T HAD A COMMITMENT FROM
THE GOVERNOR FOR DIFFERENT
PEOPLE ON HIS TEAM.
BUT I ALSO HAVE BEEN HERE LONG
ENOUGH THAT IF IT'S NOT FROM THE
BOSS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
AND SOTHAT THAT'S THAT'S MY
COMMENT OF MY CONCERN TODAY I
DON'T.
WANT TO REITERATE YOU KNOW THE
OTHER SHORTCOMINGS THAT HAVE
HAVEN'T HAD BUT THAT'S MY ISSUE
WITH THIS ALL ALONG WHETHER IT'S
TALKING ABOUT.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WHETHER THAT
THAT SHOULD BE.
ON THE PRIVATE OR PUBLIC SECTOR
OR GENERATION AND THERE'S
DIFFERENT PIECES TO THIS BUT I
DO THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A
BIGGER DISCUSSION OVERALL AND I
THINK IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
GOING TO BE HERE AGAIN JUST LIKE
I DON'T WANT TO DISCOVER
PROBLEMS.
WE ARE IN A NEW REALITY EVERY
DAY BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN.
OUT THERE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS APPRECIATED.
TO THE PROPONENTS FOR CLOTHES.
IF I CAN GO FIRST IF THAT'S OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I I'VE
ENJOYED THIS CONVERSATION AND
FACTS -- I'LL TELL YA -- WITH --
THE TO COMMITTEE HEARINGS ON A
MONDAY -- I FOUND IN THE SENATE.
AT THIS OF MY FIVE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN HERE THIS ISSUE THIS
BILL BEFORE US -- IT HAS BEEN
STUDIED AND READ THERE'S BEEN OF
INCREDIBLE AMOUNTS OF EDUCATION
ON THIS AND SO I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR WHEN WHEN FOLKS SAY YOU
KNOW THIS THING IS BEING RUSHED --
I I DO TAKE A BIT OF ISSUE WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO REPLAY ALL OF
THE TIME THAT WE HAVE SPENT.
ON THIS I IN -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SOME NUMBER BURKE LED A GROUP OF
OF LEGISLATORS ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE A BIPARTISAN WORKING GROUP
THAT THAT MET WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE THE THE LARGER QUESTIONS
BEFORE US AS IT PERTAINED TO
WILDFIRES IN THE RISKS THEY HAD
TO OUR INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
AND PUBLIC ON UTILITIES.
I WAS ON THAT WHILE WORKING
GROUP AT THE SAME TIME -- THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE CHAIR
HOLDEN ALSO HAD ANOTHER A MORE
FORMAL WORKING GROUP WHERE WE
SPENT MOST OF THE YEAR WORKING
ON SOME OF THOSE VERY SAME
THINGS WHICH ENDED UP
COMMENTATING -- IN THE NIGHT A
ONE A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
ABOUT MID YEAR LAST YEAR I HAD
COME UP WITH THIS CONCEPT OF
EXACT I WASN'T THE ONE THAT
FIRST CAME OF SOMEBODY CAME UP
WITH THIS IDEA OF A OF A RISK
POOL -- AS AT AN INSURANCE FUND
I'M AND WE BEGAN EXPLORING BUT
DURING THE NIGHT A ONE BY A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WE RAN OUT
OF A TIME AND WE KNEW THAT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS
THAT BUT THERE WAS LANGUAGE --
PUT INSIDE THAT NINE A ONE
CONFERENCE REPORT THAT SAID
WE'RE GONNA PUT TOGETHER AND I
DON'T WANT -- COMMISSION.
WE HAD A NEW GOVERNOR THE NEW
GOVERNOR CAME IN AND RIGHT AWAY.
RIGHT AWAY HE PUT TOGETHER A A
STRIKE FORCE AND SAID THAT
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS ARE GOING TO
COME OUT WITH A REPORT.
SO IN THE STRIKE FORCE REPORT
WHICH IS OUT WHICH WAS SOME SAID
NOT BOMB LIKE THE ENOUGH BUT
CAME UP WITH THIS CONCEPT OF A
WILDFIRE FUND.
AND THEN WE ENDED UP WITH -- THE
NOT A ONE CAN AND ASKING THEM TO
TO HURRY UP SO AS QUICKLY AS
THEY COULD THEY CAME UP WITH AN
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY -- AND AND
GAVE THAT TO US AND THEN AFTER
THAT EXECUTIVE SUMMARY THEY PUT
THEY THEY PUBLISH THAN A LARGER
VERSION OF IT WHICH I TALKED
ABOUT THIS THIS WILD FIRE FUND.
I HAD A BILL BACK IN JANUARY
THAT WAS INTRODUCED AND I'VE HAD
A REVOLVING DOOR STAKEHOLDERS
COMING IN AND OUT OF OF MY
OFFICE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE --
HAS HAD A BILL THAT SHE'S HAD A
A A REVOLVING DOOR STAKEHOLDERS
AND OTHER MEETINGS WITH WITH
FOLKS THIS COMMITTEE HAS TALKED
ABOUT THIS.
WE HAVE HAD -- THERE'S NOT BEEN
AN ISSUE THAT I CAN TELL YOU
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE MY FIVE
YEARS INCLUDING CAP AND TRADE.
WHAT WE HAVE SPENT THIS MUCH
TIME AND HAD THIS MUCH PUBLIC
INPUT I INTO A INTO A BILL?
AND HERE'S THE OTHER FACT IT IS
TRUE THAT JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO
WE SAW WE SAW THE THE LANGUAGE
BEFORE US AND I CAN TELL YOU IS
THE REPUBLICAN -- THAT -- ENDED
UP BEING A JOINT AUTHR ON THIS
BILL I WAS A LITTLE FRUSTRATED
I'LL TELL YOU AT FIRST NOT
HAVING ALL THE LANGUAGE WANTED
TO SEE IT UP FRONT.
SO I READ WHEN I GOT THAT EVERY
SINGLE WORD OF OF THAT OF OF
THAT BILL BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT
TO LIKE LAST YEAR.
DIDN'T WANT TO BE TOLD THAT YOU
DIDN'T READ EVERY SINGLE WORDS I
READ EVERY SINGLE WORD AND THEN
I FOUND OUT THAT THERE WERE --
SEVENTY PAGES OF AMENDMENTS THAT
I FREAKED OUT ABOUT THOSE
SEVENTY PAGES OF AMENDMENTS --
THAT THATCAME UP BE AWARE
THOUGH THAT THE WEATHER'S A
MINUTES CAME UP BECAUSE I WASN'T
THE ONLY ONE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
THERE ARE SEE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS BEHIND US THEY'RE
NOT JUST THE STATE FOR THEIR A
HUNDRED TWENTY MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE THE ALL HAD AN
OPINION OF WHAT THIS BILL MIGHT
LOOK LIKE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT THE
BILL BEFORE US TODAY IS NOT ONE
THAT IF I WAS GOING TO DO A
DRAFT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE.
I WON IT THE FACT I CAN TELL YOU
CAN POINT OUT ALL SORTS OF
THINGS IN THIS BILL THAT I THAT
I DON'T LIKE.
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US IF WE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO OFFER THE BILL IT WOULD LOOK
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT IT IS BEFORE
US TODAY.
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION ACT LIKE
AN EXECUTIVE SHOULD.
THEY LISTENED TO US THEY BROUGHT
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS IN AND THEY
CRAFTED A COMPROMISE MEASURE AND
I CAN'T THINK OF A MEASURE THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN BETTER THAN WHAT
WE HAVE TODAY.
AND IT'S FOR THAT REASON BUT
THIS IS NOT A DEMOCRATIC A BILL
IT IS NOT A REPUBLICAN BILL IT
IS A BIPARTISAN BILL IS A NON
PARTISAN BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
BECAUSE I THINK WE WERE JUST
GONNA.
YOU MADE TO CLOSE DOWN.
WE'RE ALL PLEASED ALL THREE I
MEAN I DON'T KNOW I GUESS THE
THING BUT I DO WANT TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE REMARKS -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA I MAY THINK THAT
BOTH HOLDEN AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN OUR CONVERSATIONS HAVE
BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT EXPRESSING --
EXPRESSING THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WHAT THE FUTURE.
OF THE UTILITIES LOOKS LIKE AND
I THINK -- THEY HAVE PROVEN BOTH
TO LISTEN CAREFULLY AND TO KEEP
GOOD TO THEIR WORD -- TOO SO
AMBER EGGMAN I WILL TELL YOU
THAT.
BEFORE YOU EVEN SPOKE ON AND I
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING WHAT WE
WILL BUT WHAT WILL BE DONE FOR
RELIEF FOR BOTH AG AND LARGE
ENERGY USERS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION OVER THE BREAK IN.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
VERY OPEN ABOUT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING THEM FOR THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS -- THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES
SURROUNDING THIS FUND AND I
THINK YOU KNOW AS WE TALK ABOUT
HARDENING AND PREVENTION AND
INSURANCE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ARE NOT FINISHED.
WE STILL HAVE OTHER WORK TO DO
THIS ISN'T THE END OF THE
CONVERSATION BUT THIS IS A
PIVOTAL POINT IN THE
CONVERSATION AND THIS WAS
SOMETHING.
THAT CANNOT BE PUSHED ASIDE
ANYMORE BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN THE
COST OF INACTION.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THE DEVASTATION
AND I AM SO SORRY TO THOSE
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM WHO NOT ONLY
LOST THEIR HOMES BUT HAVE LOST
FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND THAT IS THE COST THAT WE
HAVE ALL PAID FOR NOT DOING THE
PREVENTIVE MEASURES THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE DEMANDED LONG IN
ADVANCE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED IN THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS HAVE BEEN OUT OF THEIR HOME
FOR FOURTEEN HUNDRED DAYS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO LIKE YOU
HEARD TODAY OR ON THEIR PHONES
WHEN THEY LOST THEIR LOVED ONES.
WE BEAR SOME RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THAT AND TO NOT ACT WOULD BE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY SO WE DO HOLD A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SOME ACTION
AND THIS IS AN ACTION IN WHICH
WE REQUIRE.
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHERE WE COUNT AS WE REQUIRES A
SKIN IN THE GAME?
I'M NOT JUST FROM OURSELVES BUT
FROM THE UTILITIES -- AND NOT
FROM IT JUST FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ESPECIALLY FROM
THOSE WHO HAVE BEHAVED POORLY.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO I WOULD SAY -- I I AGREE WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEANS A LOT
OF WORK HAS GONE INTO THIS.
YES THIS FINAL PRODUCT IS FAIRLY
NEW BUT WE HAVE SPENT MANY
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM HAVE SPENT
HOURS.
AND DAYS AND WEEKS AND MONTHS
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES.
WE HAVE SPENT OUR FREE TIME OUR
BREAK TIME OUR WORK TIME BECAUSE
IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO US.
SO FOR THOSE WHETHER IT IS THOSE
IN OPPOSITION OR WHETHER IT IS
THE NEWSPAPERS YOU'RE WRONG.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS AND
THIS HAS BEEN IMPORTANT TO BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE.
I TELL YOU PERSONALLY I WENT TO
PARADISE AND I SAW THE
DEVASTATION.
I SAW YOUNG KIDS WHO WHO NOT
JUST A RECOVERING FROM A TRAUMA
BUT ARE AFRAID THAT THEY'RE
NEVER GOING HOME.
IT IS INCUMBENT ON US TO ACT.
AND THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
BUT IT IS OUR JOB IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN ITEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I LIKE MY COLLEAGUE I WON'T KNOW
IF I'VE ENJOYED THIS DISCUSSION
UNTIL AFTER YOU BOTH.
GET ME SITTING ON PINS AND
NEEDLES HERE -- LET ME JUST SAY
THAT -- WE JUST SAY THAT -- ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID IS IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THIS IS -- WE'RE
SITTING HERE BEFORE YOU AS
HAVING -- BEEN A PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND ABOUT ALL OF
YOU HAVE PARTICIPATED AS WELL --
WE'RE NOT IN IT.
BY OURSELVES AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING HERE IS A SOLUTION TO A
CALIFORNIA PROBLEM.
AND THAT PROBLEM IMPACTS ON OF
THE RESIDENTS THE VICTIMS.
OF THE INDUSTRY ITSELF
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I DO WE HAVE THE PERFECT PLAN
I'LL TELL YOU WE DON'T.
BUT IT IS AN INCREDIBLY GOOD
PLAN [inaudible]
THOUGHTFUL.
WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE.
WHO ARE PORING OVER THE DETAILS
WHO HAVE ENGAGED WITH US
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
[inaudible]
AND BEEN OUT.
IF WE DO NOTHING.
WHICH IS THE OTHER ALTERNATIVE
HERE.
THIS PLAN OR NOTHING.
IF WE DO NOTHING.
WE'VE HEARD THAT.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON WILL
BE DOWNGRADED. TO JUNK BOND
STATUS.
THAT MAY MEAN SOME TO SOME MEANS
SOMETHING TO SOME IT MAY MEAN
NOTHING TO OTHERS I DON'T KNOW
IT'S ON EVERYBODY'S MIND HOW
THEY WANT TO EVALUATE IT.
AND IF THEY GO TO JUNK BOND
STATUS.
AND YOU ALREADY HAVE.
A UTILITY LAST YEAR THAT WENT TO
JUNK BOND STATUS.
AND THEN THERE WAS A
CATASTROPHIC FIRE.
IN THEIR TERRITORY AND NOW
THEY'RE IN BANKRUPTCY.
WHO BENEFITED BY THAT?
THE PEOPLE WHO LOST EVERYTHING.
WERE VICTIMIZED AGAIN.
BECAUSE THEN THEY WERE DRAGGED.
INTO BANKRUPTCY WHERE THEY WENT
TO THE END OF THE LINE
[inaudible]
UNSECURED CREDITORS.
WHO LOST EVERYTHING [inaudible]
AND NOW.
THEY STAND TO LOSE AGAIN.
SO THEN THE QUESTION IS WHAT WE
DO.
DO WE LEARN.
YES IT'S NEW FRONT TIER BUT
WE'VE NOW LEARNED SOMETHING.
NOW HOW DO WE REACT TO WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED.
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT SOLUTION.
AND I THINK THAT WE'VE SAID ALL
ALONG THAT.
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER TO DAY AFTER
TOMORROW AFTER THE GOVERNOR
SIGNS THIS BILL SHOULD GET TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK IS THAT WE
STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO?
WE DON'T PACK UP AND GO AWAY
JUST BECAUSE THIS BILL PASSES
THERE ARE STAKEHOLDERS TO COME
TO THE MICROPHONE TODAY THAT WE
SAID I MADE A COMMITMENT THAT WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM.
LARGE USERS WHO REPRESENTS.
CUSTOMERS WHO USE A LOT OF POWER.
WHO ARE REALLY GOING TO TAKE IT
ON THE CHIN WITH THIS BILL?
BUT THEY'RE STANDING HERE EVEN
THOUGH THEY CAN'T SUPPORT IT.
BECAUSE IT'S A CALIFORNIA
PROBLEM THEY'RE SAYING WE'RE
PREPARED TO STAND WITH YOU.
AND NOT OPPOSE IT NOT CALL IT A
BAILOUT BUT SAY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO DO AND
WORK TOGETHER.
COLLECTIVELY AS ONE CALIFORNIA.
TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT WE ARE
ALL IMPACTED BY.
AND SO I THINK WE STAND HERE
WITH THE BEST PRODUCT THAT WE
HAVE.
RE EITHER MOVE FORWARD IN THE
MOMENT.
THINKING THAT HEY THIS WILL GET
US.
DOWN THE ROAD.
THE ISSUES THAT MR TING IS
RAISED IN HIS DISTRICT IN MISTER
TWO AND MISTER THE END SENATOR
WINNER.
THOSE ARE REAL ISSUES AND I
THINK THAT THE COMMITMENT IS
THAT THERE'S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE AND ALSO MISS SEGMENTS
DISTRICT.
THESE ARE REAL ISSUES.
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL THIS IS A
FRAGMENTED MARKET PLACE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PULL IT ALL TOGETHER
[inaudible]
AND SO -- MERCER.
TO I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU'VE DUG INTO THIS
LIKE WE ALL HAVE.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
BUT I HOPE THAT YOU WILL LOOK AT
THE FACT THAT.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE DO TAKE
SOME ACTION.
AND I'LL BE THIS NOT PERFECT I
HOPE THAT YOU'LL ALONG WITH ALL
OF YOU WILL SEE.
THAT THERE IS VALUE IN
SUPPORTING IT AND GIVING US AN
OPPORTUNITY -- TO KEEP HOPE
ALIVE.
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE MEMBERS WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRENT.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN FIFTY FOR THE MOTION IS
WITH RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
SENATE AND THEY MISS BE.
CONCURRED AND HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
BURKE HI CARILLO.
CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I IT WATER
GARCIA.
MAYES MAYES I MURATSUCHI --
SEARCHING NOT VOTING.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REYES
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TEAM [inaudible]
TING NO.
IT SAID TEN VOTES I ONE NO THE
BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
THE MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
THE BILL ON CALL FOR MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON FOR A FEW
MINUTES
--
FORTY OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO OTHER
BILLS.
AB FORTY NINE CALLING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AT WATER GARCIA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
THE MEASURE HAS.
TEN TO TWO YES.
TWENTY TWO THE HOUSE BILL.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- ITEMS
TWO ITEMS ITEM TWO THREE FOUR
EIGHT AND TEN WITH SB FIVE SIXTY
WITH THE MEMBERS GOING TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
IT WATER GARCIA SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO HI.
THAT HAS FOURTEEN VOTE. FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SB.
FIVE TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS A WATER GARCIA.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI THAT HAS.
FOURTEEN SB FIVE TWENTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
OF WATER GARCIA.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI THE MEASURE
HAS TWELVE THOUGH [inaudible]
AND SB FIVE FIFTY THE EMOTION
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
IF WATER GARCIA [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
OF AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR THE MOTION IS
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS.
WATER GARCIA [inaudible]
AS AND THE YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH. TO SAY THAT WELL WE'RE ARE
WAITING -- FOR MR GARCIA SO
WE'LL WAIT ABOUT. THREE TO FIVE
MINUTES AND THEN WE WILL CLOSE
IT DOWN
.
OKAY YEAH THAT'S FINE OKAY.
THANK YOU.
NUMBER. EIGHTY SEVEN REYES.
OKAY LET'S START BACK AT THE TOP
OF THE ROLE FOR MR GARCIA WILL
MAKE OUR WAY THROUGH.
SB FORTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- EDUARDO GARCIA
HI.
THE WATER GARCIA I THE MEASURE
HAS.
ELEVEN TO TWO WHEN I WAS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
OF ITEMS. TWO THREE FOUR EIGHT
AND NINE AND EXCUSE ME TWO THREE
FOUR EIGHT AND TEN AN ITEM TEN
SB FIVE SIXTY HAS AMENDMENTS --
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS IT'S
THE MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
DO PASS TO APPROPRIATION WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION FOR CONSENT --
IT WATER GARCIA.
HI.
THE WATER GARCIA I THAT MEASURE
HAS FIFTEEN VOTE SWITCHING
ENOUGH BEFORE THE EIGHTH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SB FIVE TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CALLING APPS THE MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA HI WATER GARCIA I THAT
MEASURE HAS FIFTEEN VOTES.
SB FIVE TWENTY FOUR MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS HAVE WATER GARCIA.
HI.
WATER GARCIA I THE MEASURE HAS
THIRTEEN VOTES.
SB FIVE FIFTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS EDUARDO GARCIA HI.
EDUARDO GARCIA I THAT MEASURE
HAS FOURTEEN VOTE.
AB FIFTEEN EXCUSE ME AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR WITH THE MOTION.
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS OF
WATER GARCIA.
WATER GARCIA I AGREE AS AND THAT
MEASURE HAS. ELEVEN ELEVEN TO
ONE FOR THAT CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA FOR TODAY WE ARE
ADJOURNED